we're live hey everybody we're bringing
you the best the brightest and also
Michael Knowles live streaming here on
both Facebook and YouTube this is our
first gathering since uh
State of Union yeah and that was a party
so they didn't let us do it again for
about three or four months now we're
having to be sitting down again with you
tonight
I'm Jeremy boring god king of the daily
wire that's lowercase G lowercase K any
actual gods or kings are registered
complain like if there's treason and
blasphemy all at once I feel like the
penalties project that's gonna be the
title of this show I think it's treason
and blast God king of the day the wire
joined by Ben Shapiro Andrew Clavin
Michael Knowles we have special guests
tonight our friend Alfonzo Rachel's
gonna join us and international film and
television star also I don't know if you
guys have heard this Peabody
award-winning no I how do we get Nick
seriously will be joining us later this
evening and we're here because Father's
Day is coming up this weekend and while
only fifty percent of us are father's
100 percent of us have fathers and
mostly we brought the cigar so we're
gonna be talking about what it's like to
be a father what it's like to appreciate
father's what it's like to be a man I
think it'll expand beyond fatherhood
obviously and into general male-female
issues because you know we're in the
middle this me to movement and as they
tell us the future is female and it
seems like that's a lot to unpack and
may be a pretty good time so here's the
part where you guys be quiet in the to
father saw tell you I have no known
children but it's a very big studly how
did he get in the building he does
anyone watch it he does not wear this to
work yeah he actually changed its once
he's here there's anything it's an awful
place to work so okay so what do you
talk about well let's talk about fathers
you are one indeed what's that
bring it to me before we get into
fathers we do have one not only non
father but not even prospective father
also part of the show tonight and that's
our friend Alicia Krause don't use
gender labels oh hi you guys are liking
this really nice Upper East Side looking
cigar lounge
I'm just doing my version of moms night
out which is Red Bull vodka and a babe
have fun I'll be here just like I was
the State of the Union taking subscriber
questions for all of y'all and I like
the idea of broadening this to like
manhood because god this world needs
more men and instead they'll have to
make do with us all right
fathers it's a very serious topic very
serious very serious nothing like my own
father who would be ashamed if you were
watching this fortunately he's working
for a living and not tuning into the
shows but I think that one of the things
that actually has always been
interesting to me about this particular
group is that we have pretty diverse
backgrounds you know drew you write a
lot about your father in your book the
good great and the great good thing and
and of course Ben we know your father
very well and I've done a lot of work
with him over the years
Michael your father who we just got to
meet this weekend at the I don't know
what how do you talk without using the
word there should've been a father
shaped all in the world that's true oh
yeah you met him this weekend at when I
took my biggest step I've ever taken to
becoming a man that's the only
contribution really and then my father
who I think of all of you yes a great
guy out in West Texas and so we we have
these diverse backgrounds and I'm sure
diverse perspectives on these issues and
yet we've all kind of come to a very
similar place one of the things this is
my surprise the audience that we talk a
lot about these issues when we're not
talking about politics and we really
because we talk about politics
professionally our hobby is not also
talking about politics so this is some
of I think fertile ground for what our
conversations are actually like and
that's why we're calling the show I
don't know if you guys got the memo we
named it the show so previously the show
was just called like State of the Union
coverage at a roundtable involving four
guys and cigars it really wasn't much of
a much of a title and now we've named it
the Daily wire backstage wow it's pretty
good anyway you smoke and drink in your
office you can call it whatever you want
this is the greatest job ever recommend
page just welcome to sit around talk and
the people paying us are actually
probably hoping for a shout out now
Dollar Shave Club Oh Dollar Shave Club
so if you don't want to look like
Knowles
if you actually make something of your
life if you want to you know have the
best products available if you want to
have all of the best stuff I mean we are
talking here the shampoo the conditioner
the body
wash the toothpaste the hair Jo and even
that wipe that leaves your ass feeling
tingling then you absolutely need to
shop with Dollar Shave Club true yes you
don't look like Knowles glory to Dollar
Shave I was a member of Dollar Shave
Club before I we the daily wire even
existed I loved it to death I do because
you know I start shaving on Thursday to
come in on Monday that's a lot of real
estate to shave and they have great
blades they come in the mail every month
they come with all those you can put
those things in the box and just order
them right up you get the full kit and I
use the whole at the whole deal I take
their premium blades
I started out cheap with the double
blade I got to the premium blade the
premium blade is great because you start
it's got so many blades in it if we
start dragging it over your hair about
five o'clock and by 5:30 you've kind of
made it and it works I mean it's like
you know so my wife is a big fan of the
amber the calming body cleanser because
as you can tell I'm just a calm guy
exactly right the other day my wife said
you smell great what is it that you're
using and I said well it's that cleanser
and it's that magical calming body
cleanser because it definitely was not
my natural oh that's my wife offered
ordered up the ass wipes and she suspend
like moving right along that's right
there daily essential starter said it
comes with body cleanser one wipe
Charlies those are the incredible ass
wipes they get rid of their right and
their world-famous shea butter their
best razor the six blade executive keep
the blades coming for a few bucks more
every month and you add in the shampoo
toothpaste or anything else that you
need for the bathroom you can check it
all out at dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben you
get that special deal with the daily
essential starter set it's all awesome
stuff dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben go
check it out great thing to get your dad
for Father's Day so my dad was actually
like a stay-at-home dad basically so he
was a musician who wrote for some film
and TV but he stayed home a lot more of
my mom my mom was the one who actually
was working outside the house a lot more
which means that I'm extraordinarily
tight with my dad I know your dad was it
was a radio host he was a big shot radio
host in New York kind
for there were national radio hosts like
Rush you know people who would actually
there was some syndication but mostly
were a local guy but New York was the
biggest market and he was the biggest
guy with the old John gambling the two
of them traded off the number one spot
for 25 years and he went to what I gotta
say the one thing that was really cool
about my old man is he went to work at 3
o'clock in the morning every day and he
treated it like a job
we hardly knew he was in show business I
mean one of the reasons I became a
writer is cuz I thought the arts were
something you could do I thought it was
like a job doctor lawyer writer if I had
known how hard he was working I probably
would've been a little nicer to him not
much just briefly on your dad it's hard
for us to probably relate now that
because of things like syndication and
because everything sort of national even
cable makes television national but the
idea of a local radio host is such an
intimate Heat celebrity you know and as
you say in New York and the biggest time
I mean your dad wasn't just in showbiz
he was a giant we are we called him the
mayor of 46th Street because you would
literally walk down certain streets in
Manhattan and people would lean out of
buildings to wave to him everybody knew
who he was I mean that for for many many
years when I would use a credit card or
somebody the first thing somebody would
say is oh you must be you know Clavin
and finches he worked with a partner and
so he really was a local celebrity
nobody knew him outside of New York but
the first first job I ever got was in
radio not the first job I ever got but
the first adult job I got was in radio I
went in and did the worst audition of my
life looked up and saw a promotional
card from my father and blurted out
that's my dad when your dad wasn't
beating you like a redheaded stepchild
so my dad so unlike us you know we sit
around spread fake news for a living you
know my dad works with the mentally
so it's kind of like social
work you know and it was interesting
because my parents divorced when I was
very little before I really was
conscious or anything but I didn't
realize that divorce is terrible because
I saw my dad every day he was right
nearby picked me up from school you know
so I'd see him every single day and it
was a unique experience because only
later did I realize look
statistics looking with divorce really
usually means for people I didn't
realize that experience you know I got
to see him every day he go to work very
early be out basically in time to pick
me up from school and yeah but it's a
totally different you know it's such a
totally different career field your
father was a writer your father is a
broadcaster you know you fell into that
broad genre and I'm you know my father
working with these this poor community
and doing all this good work and I just
did exactly the opposite for so many
people responsibility I do it I weep
about it every day and your dad what is
it so my dad's an engineer for the
railroad and you know that's the guy
drives the train so he's a locomotive
engineer and he you know your dad's the
coolest that's the but it's a tough job
you know people may not know railroaders
are on 24-hour call so you know my
childhood was sort of this weird not
knowing when you would see your dad even
though he and my mom happily married to
this day yeah he would
you know sometimes he'd get called at
2:00 in the morning and be gone for
maybe three days and sleep in the hotel
and then he'd get back at 6:00 in the
afternoon he may not go to work again
for 24 hours or he may go to work again
12 hours later and so there was you know
especially early on when he had less
seniority in the career and could maybe
pick as his runs a little less you know
he would be kind of gone from certain
important events as he's you know as his
as his career sort of took shape he had
a lot more flexibility I think my little
sister and my little brother probably
got a lot more of them in some ways than
I did but that's not a it's not exactly
a complaint what I actually feel like is
you know my mom and dad I got pregnant
very young and my dad basically had to
make a decision to keep being a kid or
to be a father and he took the best job
that he could find as a guy in a small
town you know without a college
education he hired onto this difficult
job that isn't hard in the way of manual
labor I mean it's not like he's you know
busting moving breaking ditches but that
has this other kind of isolating
difficulty of always being tired working
nights and days and nights and days and
being away from your family and and I I
feel like from the the guy that I know
is the product in many ways of those
hard and isolating years where he kind
of found himself out on the road and so
I'm I've always been very appreciative
of it so what okay so since Father's Day
is coming up what's the best one lesson
that your dad's taught you'll again to
boil it down to one lesson I taught you
well what's the lesson that your dad
taught yeah I you know my dad and I
didn't get along that well we have very
different points of view and there's one
piece of advice he gave me which I
simply can't say on the air it's so fun
I can translate it I can translate it
into speakable English which was when
when I I became a man a young man in the
60s when suddenly sex was available so
we went from literally one year I would
have said oh you never have sex until
you get married to two years later
everybody was available and I said how I
put this
he basically well I think I translated
this he said basically just remember
every vagina comes with a human being
attached about anything it turns out to
be exactly true yeah that's pretty good
pretty amazing you know I think the the
best advice I got for I couldn't sum it
up into a line but I do kind of get it
from my father's dispositional
conservatism and that's a different
thing than like you know I don't know
voting for Trump or low taxes or
whatever that dispositional conservatism
of you know when I had tough times or my
family had tough times he would just do
what he had to do yeah and wasn't
Pleasant and it was costly and difficult
he would just do it and wouldn't talk
about it and wasn't a bit and just kind
of do it you know and when there would
be social questions obviously we live in
this kind of crazy social moment where
you know I I think I now legally have to
use the girls room when I go to market
but there was this kind of sense of the
tradition this kind of sense of the this
is normal it's a good thing to go to
church it's a good thing to do that's a
good that I you know I see it being lost
because I look at my friends I see I
even look at my friend's parents and
that kind of conservatism is
I'll even let you vote for a Democrat if
you have that I think that's a really
important thing I can really relate to
that because my dad was that it is and
discipline say
dispensationalism yeah not dispensation
at all that would be the more religious
that conservative you know he was a
union Democrat for most of my childhood
because he works for the railroad you
know but was always very very
conservative in terms of his values and
really even in in a term in terms of his
politics and and pass that along to me
and also just the selfishness
selflessness to be able to always do the
thing that he didn't want to do but that
needed doing which I I feel like is not
only lost from the culture but I'll say
it's even lost from me personally I am
NOT selfless in the way that my father
was selfless and so I should give him
credit for that very thing as being his
greatest advice but he did articulate
advice from time to time never quite as
good as the advice that he tried to live
out but a lot more funny so I was at a
blockbuster video which if you recall
blockbuster videos from your YouTube
people used to go and rent Michael
they're going rent DVDs or VHS tapes and
they would take them home and put them
in a machine and you could watch was
that in the old timey days whenever and
we were in a Blockbuster Video in
Lubbock the kind of big city in near the
small town that I'm from and my dad and
I are you know looking to see what we're
gonna get or whatever and this guy comes
in and back then there were late fees
that's the other thing you had late fees
and what that is is a fee for being late
okay yeah so guys up at the front he
wants to rent something new and the
little 16 year old girl or whatever run
in the counter can't help him because
you can't rent something when you have
late fees and she's like sir I'm sorry
you know the system says you owe us 1350
and you know I'd be happy to process
that payment if you want amazing this is
an outrage right I mean I don't have
1350 I'm here to rent splash to or
whatever it was
how dare you not want to talk to your
manager and you know the girl starts to
get very upset she's quite young you
know and this is a grown man he's being
very aggressive if she starts to kind of
get flustered in the little teary and
her voice is breaking and he just is
relentless I actually believe she
eventually let him just rent the DVD and
my father I remember this like it was
yesterday turns to me and he says son
never be an over 13:50 stood me
well so for me there were a couple so
one was that when I was in junior high I
had already skipped third grade and went
to junior high I went to a highly gifted
magnet she had take an IQ test to get
into this magnet school and I got in but
I was certainly not the person with the
highest IQ there there are people who
there's a there's a girl there who had I
remember a 180 IQ and did you even talk
at that this is the part that was
actually kind of funny so I I you know
my dad basically said to me at that time
that most of the time you're not gonna
be the smartest person in the room now
that's an exception here in the room
which means really have to work
extraordinarily hard and the payoff to
that story is that the girl with the 180
IQ now teaches Jim it like Michigan
State or something because and virtually
everybody in the class you had a higher
IQ than mine ended up you know doing
stuff that was probably less lucrative
than the stuff that we do for a living
so that was that was piece of advice
number one which is that your natural
gifts only take you a certain amount of
the way that was that's something my
fourth-grade teacher also told me she's
she was she gave me a very dark piece of
advice for a fourth player she said
don't let potential be written on your
tombstone no it was really good but I'm
a nine year old been said that he that
he always said was that never start a
fight but the end if I finish it which I
have a feeling all of us probably heard
from our DS yes that's my dad actually
did tell me one time I was being picked
on by this kid at the at the we'd go to
the high school basketball games come
from a small town and there's nothing
literally nothing else to do except
watch girls basketball so the whole
family's at the ball game and I don't
know I'm probably like 11 and
highschool kid would bully me anytime
that I was a at the gym it's uh my dad
kind of caught wind of this and I don't
think he understood the age dynamics at
play because someone was bullying me and
he said son you stand up for yourself
you know if you if you hit the bully
back they go away you usually don't even
have to hit the bully back if they say
they're gonna punch you just look them
in the eye and say fine then punch me
get it over with
I just we need to live you know you just
have to be a man so you know Here I am
in I'm 11 and I have thing is my dad he
must know it so sure enough pulled me
aside you know coming out the bathroom
at high school Germany I don't know ask
me for my money or whatever it was that
he used to do picking on me and I said
no and he says give me your money or
I'll kick your butt you know I'm
probably a little bit more harsh
language and I said if you're gonna
punch me just punch me he did teach me
some of the dirtiest fighting I was in a
lot of fights I was on a lot of fist
place and he used it I thought you lost
a fist fight he would come home and say
let me show you something and then he
told me something I can't even say in
the air we'd be arrested like nine is I
killed him I'm sorry yeah I seem to
recall you what you would say I've
broken my nose on a number of occasions
that was one of the ways I broke my the
father's give very good advice they
don't give exclusively we should still
celebrate them with Omaha Steaks
Omaha Steaks for Father's Day can you
find a better deal you cannot because
right now is giving you a life a limited
time offer to our listeners go to Omaha
Steaks calm and type in Shapiro and in
the search bar you can get the Omaha
steak Father's Day package for just
forty nine ninety nine which is seventy
nine percent off and here are all the
things the again I'm gonna have Jeremy
describes you in delectable detail how
awesome these things are cuz I can't eat
the steaks but he can I spent the entire
weekend eating the steak because Omaha
Steaks is such a good company they sent
me the Father's Day package the one of
the 50% of non father's on the panel
absolutely an injustice and I thought
about calling drew and going to her I
think these are problem and these are
amazing so the Omaha Steaks that they're
they're hand trimmed flash-frozen
vacuum-sealed directly delivered to your
door in the Omaha Steaks cooler and they
are customized so you can customize
cuts for the grilling needs and here's
what you got in that special package
they get the $49.99 package and here's
when it comes with two tender filet
mignons two beefy top sirloins four
chicken-fried steaks two boneless pork
chops great for me well not great for me
great for Jeremy Omaha steak burgers for
gourmet jumbo Franks 12 ounces of all
beef meatballs one pound of steak house
fries for caramel apple tartlets one
Omaha steak seasoning packet and you get
four more grill ready Omaha steak
burgers for free with the purchase
that's a pretty solid deal for $49.99
it's freaking delicious and it filled up
my entire freezer and then my wife
thought that I had done something great
like accomplished something in my career
possibly won the lottery and I I told
her that it was true she should cook the
steak as a sign of her appreciation of
me she did not cook the steak with a
little thyme and a little garlic butter
and I will say this as a Texan a man who
has eaten a lot of red meat in my life
you know sometimes for like as a child
in Texas they wean you you know with
directly to red meat I have to say it
was these are freaking good today you
get the limited time package right now
for $49.99 when you go to Omaha Steaks
calm and Ted Shapiro in the search bar
now the Father's Day package for your
card now you should get it for Father's
Day but the deal is available a little
bit after Father's Day as well but don't
wait because the offer does end soon it
will be available again to everyone who
don't get you don't get your stuff your
dad the thing for Father's Day because
you're lazy bum you can still do it
afterwards go to go to Omaha Steaks calm
and type Shapiro's into the search bar
and grab your dad and fire up the grill
and as you've heard from all of these
various fine gentlemen and knowles the
[Laughter]
search I like Father's Day because your
father is the one guy who can't actually
be mad if you were late getting him the
gift we have Alicia I think taking some
questions from the audience from our
subscribers this is important if you if
you want to ask a question you must
first subscribe if you subscribe you get
access not only to ben shapiro show the
andrew Clavin show the michael knowles
show you also get as everyone I think
probably knows by now the leftist tears
hot or cold daily wired tumblr with the
annual where the annual must you must
give us all of your money in order to
get the tumblr we aren't we are not
generous hey Lisa what do we got we have
lots of great questions first I have to
say I'm totally in bear
that I used to actually intern for John
gambling and I had no idea that our
great Andrew kleavon's father was be she
yeah there you go yeah John Cantlie he
was terrific I worked I worked I was a
news writer on his show Wow when I first
started in journalism yeah I love that
story I loved it so much so Evan asked
the god-king both little G and little K
because we're not blasphemous around
here who is the better father figure to
aspire to be Kirk Picard Sisko or Archer
well that's a fantastic question I don't
believe that Picard was a father Archer
had a dog he loved very much see if I
can make it all the way through Cisco I
was a good father you know he except not
the best advice to like take your son to
the farthest outpost in the Federation
and subject them to like Kardashian
invasion and Klingon war but listen it's
the future and they have a little bit
different set of mores but Kirk Kirk is
the greatest father and here's why
because if you are going to be a
spectacularly bad father and Kirk was
certainly that the best thing that you
can do is never even introduce yourself
to your son until he is 30 and then show
up just in time to you know save him
from the Genesis experiment all that
kind of stuff okay
fascinating I could just barely hold in
my enthusiam Marshall asks Ben do you
think utilizing bad examples is a good
way to pant parent for instance to teach
my kids to be nice should I show them
how mean you are to Michel Noel's not to
be like Ben is to Michael Noel's so I
the answer generally that is given at
least by most of the people who have
studied this stuff is that using bad
examples is not good because your kid
learns the bad example so this is so you
should not like show your kids people
doing terrible things and don't do that
because instead they learn to do that
thing so generally no but in in this
case with me abusing no absolutely you
know even in adulthood it's a problem I
remember when I first
move to LA you know little guy from a
little Christian guy from West Texas and
you don't know anybody and you fall in
with a group of other Christian guys are
kind of out here in the world and just
trying to make their way and I became a
part of what was by all accounts an
accountability group which is a Bible
study but where you don't really read
the Bible you just tell each other about
all the mistakes that you're making in
life and then you're like oh yeah yeah
that's terrible and I'll never forget
that a few years later when it sort of
transitioned into more of a Bible study
and we're really learning things one of
the guys missed the old accountability
days and he didn't like the Bible study
because it got a little controversial
and with a little bit esoteric at times
and he said you know I don't I don't
like coming here and just talking about
all this like philosophical stuff I miss
the old days when we used to just
support each other and build each other
up you know and I would tell you about
my mistakes and you would tell me about
your mistakes and back then
because I was teaching the Bible study
this time but he pointed the guy you
used to teach it it said back then you
were the teacher and you were just such
him I just liked it so much better than
this yuk yuk you know being the teacher
I'll never forget that that guy the
original teacher said yeah but there was
always a problem because you know how
you used to come and like talk about all
the women you were sleeping with and
then we would all pray for you you would
cry we would all pray for you
he said yeah yeah it was good for me yes
yeah but I had never slept with a woman
and all I could think was my god that
sounds great yeah there's there's some
pretty good empirical support for the
idea that when you see people do bad
things that you actually are more likely
to think about doing those bad things
yourself it's almost like they don't
think of a pink elephant effect or you
tell somebody don't think of a pink
elephant immediately everybody's
thinking of a pink elephant yeah you'll
say Ben's abuse of me has already made
me an abusive father I'm teaching my
daughters yes you should treat men like
Michael no leash owed that I guess
cigarette sales with and whiskey sales
went up during every season of Mad Men
that there was like this increased
interest in you know casually or
socially smiling after watching this
interestingly drunk driving incidents
went down during the heyday of Cheers
being on the air because even though
they all got together and drank every
day they never went out and drove drunk
it was no as a point on the show right
if someone was drunk you'd make sure
they got a cab you know the other people
would care for them and not allow them
to go out oh wow
interesting Bradley asks what do
children who have bad fathers or fathers
who aren't involved at all do where do
they look to learn what it means to be a
real man well I can tell you that I
earned two literature's actually one of
the starts without my love for
literature is you know my father my
father wasn't a bad person he was a good
guy but he and I just didn't get along
and he didn't really think very much of
me and at which which we can understand
but but but I turned to the tough guys
of literature I turned to Raymond
Chandler and read about Philip Marlowe
the detective and I turned to Dashiell
Hammett and Hemingway and all those guys
and ultimately found role models in
those people guys I sculpted myself
after I imitated them I'd imitate the
way they talk and ultimately I kind of
constructed an idea of what a man should
be
Hemingway was your example now my
example of good father would have a good
man what a man was supposed to be you
know a man did that you know Raymond
Chandler said down these mean streets a
man must go who is not himself mean and
that struck me as a very good good woman
you know I have the millennial version
of that which is obviously we don't read
ever our write books Harry Potter
yeah but it Nick at night was actually
the answer because when I was growing up
they Nick at night had all these cheap
reruns of these shows from the 50s and
60s so all the shows that I was Lucy I
Love Lucy where I Love Lucy father knows
best Leave It to Beaver all these and
that really does or Archie Bunker that's
why I like Donald Trump and so there
were all of these great examples of
father figures that are utterly absent
on modern television there's actually
really fascinating so for those who
don't know I wrote an entire book about
the history of television and one of the
chapters in the book I talk about the
evolution of fatherhood on TV and there
is this amazing evolution of fatherhood
that happened for social reasons where
the left started pushing the idea that a
woman was liberated if there was no
father in the home and you know
everything from Murphy Brown to the
Simpsons basically portrays fatherhood
as useless if you are father the most
famous fathers on TV in the last 30
years Robin doofuses
right I mean Homer Simpson is a doofus
Phil Dunphy who's seen as like a good
guy he still a doofus he's an idiot I
I only think Modern Family is the best
written comedy I'll get out work
television I can't watch it because of
the religion right every and every
father on TV every major show on TV has
a father John Goodman on Roseanne every
father on TV is either backwards or
stupid or just a bloviating dolt and
that's not how all of these things were
modeled like if you go back and watch
the Dick Van Dyke Show Dick Van Dyke is
a good father right he's somebody who
even though he's kind of klutzy he's a
good guy he knows what he's doing for
the most part and that's certainly true
in shows like father's knows best or the
Waltons okay I grew up on my dad used to
go to Eddie Brant Saturday matinee and
rent all those tapes used to watch
nothing but old shows and there was this
purposeful attempt in the 1970s and 80s
to move away from the model of the
father who at the end of the show would
actually try to model the behavior the
last gasp of it probably was actually
family Tung definitely ties records the
dad and family ties was but he was a
liberal rights the idea was that he was
liberal lecturing his way bored a
conservative son Michael Michael J Fox
about why he shouldn't be conservative
anymore but TV has moved to I mean you
can't name by making the husband father
character on television a lovable doofus
there at least making him lovable and if
they prove if they present him as
masculine and strong he is not lovable
in the sort of value set of the people
who write motion but and this was it but
this is what so hilarious is that if you
actually watch the sitcoms at work the
ones that work now are the ones that
actually have a deeply conservative
character who immediately becomes the
most popular character on the show
because in fact a father figure right if
you watch Parks and Rec and you welcome
Ron Swanson Ron Swanson is the most
popular character on the show and he is
Leslie Knope father figure she comes to
him for advice he tells her what to do
he's grumpy he's conservative the same
thing is true of Alec Baldwin in 30 rock
oh yeah he does the same thing for Tina
Fey it's exactly the same sort of thing
it merely speaks to a larger issue the
responsibility of the people who make
these things that they actually are you
know one of the things we heard
especially is the 60s and 70s and 80s
came on as we would hear from sports
figures and we'd hear from actors well
you know I'm not a role model I'm just
doing I just do this for a living but
they actually are they actually with
their fame as spider-man will tell them
with you know with those who have much
have great responsibility
you know this these things really do
fizz that is the part that drives me and
give us a chance to look for something
that maybe we can't find it on and
drives me up a wall because you see all
these people who are immensely wealthy
immensely successful so they can't
afford
to get married right they have two kids
out of wedlock and they're still not
married and so why are you not married
like what what sort of example are you
setting not only for your own kids but
what sort of example are you setting for
the society at large
yeah Charles Marie has a great book
called coming apart about this this this
exact phenomenon where you have a bunch
of kind of white liberals Uppercross
liberals who don't actually live this
this sort of lifestyle they actually get
married they actually have kids but then
they tell everybody that's bad to get
married and have kids and so everybody
who's watching the culture they say oh
you're right you know it's bad to get
married and have kids because look what
they're saying on TV but all the rich
white liberals are still getting married
and having kids like the marriage rates
among rich white liberals are much
higher than the marriage rates among
poor white people living in Appalachia
he has the line they don't they don't
preach what they practice which i think
is it is this incredible insistence on
tolerance and open-mindedness it
actually is it broke down the walls of
the good kind of discrimination which is
discrimination between good and bad
discrimination between wise and unwise
and they've thrown that away with the
other kinds of discrimination which may
be uncertain you know the marriage rates
among from boomers to the Millennials
have dropped from ninety-one percent
down to at the rosiest
expectations seventy percent among
Millennials that numbers been dropping
over generations but that is very low
and it could be lower than that where
does that come from it comes from the
culture that you're stood in that you
come that you're raised up in and
they're lying to everybody by the way I
mean then when they say that great
happiness is in avoiding marriage and
pursuing career these people are idiots
you mean idiots the truth is that
marriage is the greatest thing that has
happened to women and it is the greatest
thing that has happened to men marriage
is a wonderful wonderful thing every
poll ever done shows that married people
are happier than single people and by
the way have happier sex lives than
single people as well despite all the
mythology that you see on television and
what the studies also tend to show this
is this one's interesting that kind of
like this one but they show about having
kids is that people who either have no
kids or many kids are happiest if you
have one kid you're not as happy because
you've ordered all of your hopes and
dreams into this one guy out there but
if you have seven kids you okay they're
running around like knocking each other
over and as a society we've decided that
we're not going to make the decisions
that are necessary to preserve our own
happiness and that's why you're seeing a
bunch of people who are particularly for
women who actually do have a biological
clock I can get married at 50 and he's
still gonna have kids but if a girl gets
married at 45 you know she might be done
before we before we continue I want to
let Alicia go and say thank you Alicia
for
questions we'll see in a few minutes if
you want to reach out to me Alicia right
now so that you can get a question in to
the panel or to any of our guests who
are coming up throughout the rest of the
broadcast head on over to the Daily wire
comm become a premium subscriber you can
give us $9.99 a month or you can become
an annual subscriber you will get the
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr it is
the best way to drink leftist tears it's
scientifically scientifically proven I
just want to address this thing about
happiness when they always take these
polls about happiness a lot of funds
I've heard them say well parents with
their children at home are not that
happy
you know happiness is kind of overrated
I mean happiness is something you feel
when things are going well which is
great and everybody loves it but the
thing about having children is they make
you more alive you are both happier and
sadder you're both more afraid and more
hopeful every everything about life
becomes bigger and more dimensional and
adds dimensions you didn't even you
thought you were seeing in three
dimensions but suddenly you realize you
weren't at all this is my whole theory
about the spectrum of life so when you
when you are single then your spectrum
of happiness and sadness goes down to a
zero and up to maybe a seven and then
when you get married your spectrum of
happiness goes down to a negative ten
and up to a fifteen right and because
now you actually care about what happens
the other person like when you're single
you don't have another person to worry
about when something happens to your
spouse it's obviously awful for you and
when something great is happening with
you and your spouse it's just wonderful
and then when you have kids then all
barriers are removed then it's the worst
stuff that has ever happened when
something bad happens to your kid it is
the worst thing that has ever happened
to you in the history of time and when
something great happens with your kid it
is the best thing that has ever happened
to you in the history of time it's an
incredible incredible thing and you
don't really experience it sort of like
a cult you're recruiting them into a
call you don't tell them about the
downside don't tell me on the outside
and then once they're in and they
realize that they're in this cult and
they have that tattoo of the children
you know then and then they can't get
out and then it's their job to recruit
others in each other I want to talk more
about that in particular I don't have
children so I don't try to recruit
people into that cold but I do often
tell people including the people who
work for us which I'm almost sure will
cost us our company at some point in the
future in a future court settlement that
the best way to become a happier person
right now would be to walk out onto the
street and just marry the first member
of the opposite sex who passes you hi
and a lot of homeless people like I did
yeah
but that marriage is so fulfilling and
changes you so fundamental of itself in
and of itself that you should you should
pursue it let's get to that but first
let's talk about expressvpn another one
of our sponsors for tonight is made it
possible for us to have this thrilling
conversation and more importantly these
delicious delicious you may have noticed
that AT&T and Time Warner actually
merged today so there's a there's a
judge who ruled that that merger could
go forward well good for them except for
the fact that there are all these
massive companies they all have control
over your data and they're using that
data for many a thing so Michael Knowles
you surf the internet a fair bit what do
you do with that internet that your wife
is watching well this is the real thing
if you guys are anything like me I think
you fellas are and maybe you look at
some weird stuff on the internet I'm
talking about I'm talking about the
daily wife and I actually I really have
used VPNs a long time from my first
political campaign I ever worked on
political operatives said you got to use
VPNs because everybody is looking at
your data and we know this now I mean
how many emails have you gotten in the
last three weeks the privacy alert I
know all your data is being thrown
everywhere it's being all these internet
service providers all the tech companies
right
VPNs expressvpn is really really good it
is an rated number one by TechRadar it
is less than seven bucks a month you can
protect all of your information your IP
address you you know your wife might
still be looking over your shoulder so
watch out but other than that it is
really good and it's a must-have in
today's world you need to use a VPN or
you're crazy I mean your your
information is everywhere you have got
to use it
they have blazing fast service it's very
inexpensive I've clearly good you know I
was after talking to Knowles today I put
it in I installed it today it took me
about 90 seconds and then it runs in the
background on your computer on your
phone it's really really convenient and
right now you can have a special deal go
over to expressvpn comm /ban you get
your first 3 months for free so
expressvpn calm /ban when you buy a
one-year package you get your first 3
months for free and every day you're
using the internet without Express BPM
you're exposing your information so
don't be that person
don't go to Starbucks and expose your
information to the public Wi-Fi instead
use Express VPN then you can use the
public Wi-Fi you don't have to worry
about it expressvpn comm slash Ben and
again you get that first three months
for free with one-year subscription
again expressvpn comm slash Ben to check
it out there's Ben get
pretty much all the credit for any sales
that happen every single one of our
sponsors is using a /bin I noticed
there's no like / the god-king this is
part of Ben's long scheme to fire me
it's not the short I thought it was a
trapdoor he was building the hall I like
what we're talking about a second ago
which is just the idea of recruiting
people into the cult of happiness and
you may be happiness is the wrong word
maybe it's the cult of fulfillment
because your purpose yeah meaning or
purpose you're right that happiness is a
shallow concept although I do feel that
a fair amount of happiness actually
comes from being fulfilled well not to
get to aristotelian but that's basically
Aristotle's argument right yeah you have
to you have to the man who lives the
good life in accordance with right
reason and virtue ends up living a happy
life over the course of their entire
life and he says specifically that if
you're happy at any one given moment of
your life this does not make you a happy
person you really only get to determine
your happiness when you die as you get
to the very end of your life and you
realize you lived a happy life actually
the best example of that in the last
several weeks was the Krauthammer letter
right charles krauthammer is is passing
away and the letter that he wrote is
just beautiful where he said are you I
feel like it really was I mean it's like
I've reached into my life and I really
have no regrets and I've lived the life
that I wanted to live and so you know if
you can reach the on your life and that
can be what what it is then then you've
done the right thing and that requires
actual purpose it's not just you going
to Cancun on vacation it actually what
are the wonderful people like us though
is that we now have to be sort of
evangelists for things that were
ubiquitous among almost by rote so
obviously marriage is one of those
things child having children is another
one because they've become sort of a
spouse as a commodity now and a child is
a commodity now you have to choose them
you have to choose them above others you
know you choose them in comparison to
other choices that could possibly be
made whereas in the past that the
society even if people didn't have the
right values or they didn't have the
right beliefs they certainly existed in
a culture where they were pointed in
these directions so you know one of the
things that we read about all the time
is how much it will cost you to have a
kid and I think about the value
proposition of marriage or the value
proposition of having children it used
to be that society was structured in
such a way that instead of reading in
the New York Times
oh if I have a
child this year it will cost me two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
if you're the average American you're
making like fifty grand a year and if
you work for been on the Michael Nolan
extra making like so you read this
staggering number it's gonna cost me a
quarter of a million most people never
even lay eyes on a quarter of a million
dollars whereas historically there was
actually a value proposition to these
things right you got married as a way of
increasing your prosperity of increasing
your wealth you a spouse then gave you
children and those children were able to
work in your work in your holdings or
properties and that increased your
wealth and then as you got older you
wanted to have many children so that as
you got older your children would
eventually be able to inherit from you
what you had done in life and then pour
some of it back towards some small piece
of it back towards you if you had six
children they each gave you a sixth of
their income now the state has slowly
replaced all of the value that we were
supposed to gain from marriage or that
we're supposed to gain from having
children and not only that they've taken
away any opportunity for you to gain
value uh any obvious value you know if
you get married as the culture says you
will have less freedom you will have
less opportunity well we know none of
that's true but because you're being fed
that you know non-stop forty hours a
week as most people engage in culture
they become sort of a heuristic truth
you know it's back there in the lizard
brain as the truth if a children are
gonna cost you two hundred fifty
thousand dollars you can't work them in
your fields or you're abusive you know
you're not though you're not the head of
your house in the sort of biblical
marriage sense you know your wife will
now rule over you in every way they've
sort of taken all the incentives and
perverted them and then also then
replace those incentives with the hand
of the state so that now it actually is
difficult to convince people that a
spouse is not a commodity a spouse is a
spouse you have a choice
but even a even a choice that isn't
perfect will be far superior to never
choosing to take that right or no
they've made it's really I don't believe
the state is necessarily to blame for
this I think the industrialization took
a lot of home home economy home
businesses and took them out to the
factory and children
left home went to work in the cities
which they hadn't done before so I think
it just developed with technology but
it's absolutely true that having
children is now complete outlet and
economically that a woman has lost a
homemaker has lost her economic value
that she used to have when she would do
home industries and all this and it has
changed everything
but the one thing that remains true is
that marriage and children is this high
spiritual achievement that enriches your
life right joy
so we've detached it's a weird thing
we've detached the economic reward from
the spiritual reward which could in some
sense have a good effect right people
opt for the spiritual turn into the the
the reward that you get from your spouse
is that your spouse makes you happier in
the generic sense not that your marriage
makes you happier like there's a
difference to your spouse making you
happier in your marriage making you're
happier how that's all your children
making you happier you know just having
children like the fact is that you put
your value as a human being in your
status in various things that you do
what your status is as a husband or your
status as a father your status in a job
and we've detached all that and so it's
turned into well what makes me happy
about my spouse is that my spouse does X
for me so if my spouse doesn't do X for
me that I'm not appreciative with my
spouse and I spent why should I have
this balance why shouldn't I just go get
another spouse or my kids aren't making
me better come on right now stop them
against other option that's right I mean
the whole purpose of marriage was
supposed to be that marriage made you a
better person not that it necessarily
made you a happier person right you were
going to be a happier person because you
were a better person but part of being a
better person is learning to live with
difficulty and learning to live with
pain and learning to not let it all you
know get in your head in this virtually
every philosophy Eastern and Western
suggests that how you respond to actual
things that happen to you to find your
level of happiness it's not the stuff
that happens to you that matters nearly
as much as how you respond to the stuff
that happens to you whether you're a
Buddhist or whether you're a Christian
or whether you're a Jew and what that
really means is that as a society we've
decided that the only way that we can
actually make ourselves happier is to
change the material circumstances that
surround us we can become richer or we
can have more beautiful people who
surround us or we can have better kids
who are more well trained by various by
various sources but the reality is that
what makes you a happier person a better
person is you learning that crap happens
and then you have to deal with it and
how are you going to deal with are you
gonna deal with it in a way that's
productive even though either way this
is good or not even though I think this
is important and true it is a spiritual
truth what you're saying but it's
so that in the same way that capitalism
hasn't made the poorer poor and
corporations haven't made the world less
free and you know logging hasn't
resulted in less trees in the sense that
everything the culture tells us is a lie
it is also my truth it is also a truth I
have observed that men get married and
then they make more money no sure you
can have children and then they do
become happier so I completely agree
with the spiritual concept that yes true
happiness is not happiness in a moment
and true fulfillment is not getting
exactly what you want and yet married
people get more of what they want are
more superficially happy and are more
deeply fulfilled and that says totally
true but I think we do I would just be
careful in necessarily its its usual but
not necessary
I agree meaning that it's it that that's
that is the usual process because like
it may be badly - right I mean that's
also true but it bottom line is that I
think what religion teaches and what you
know good values teach is that you make
good decisions and good things generally
happen you but not that they always
happen to you and I think it's important
to separate those two things out because
otherwise people have unrealistic
expectations that if something bad
happens it's because this is what Jimmy
was saying before about that if you
walked out in the street and married a
random woman you'd still be happier the
point is that when you get married to
someone if you do it right right you
invest yourself in other people and once
you do that you are so liberated and so
free and you understand life so much
better than you do if you're completely
invested in yourself you can you can be
married badly not in the sense that you
marry the wrong person but in the sense
that in being married you remain selfish
you remain independent you remain
uncaring and that's not gonna help you
well I agree and I think that's why you
know that the model of arranged marriage
I'm not a fan of right arranged
marriages did work for thousands of
years from people specifically because
of the idea that you're saying I
actually want to follow up on that
because I kind of do believe in arranged
marriage but first I want to welcome our
first guest for the night one of I think
the favorite people of everyone except
Ben for whom no personal thanks for
hanging with us thanks for having me
before before I talk about arranged
marriage do you want to pollute your
body with the fine incense well I was
trying to figure man do I want popcorn
and do I want a cigar and you know it
driving up your meters a big fire like
yeah and I was like worried that's it
man I'm gonna go in there smelling like
smoke I felt bad because I tossed my
embers out there we do have we have some
delicious options for you either way you
want and you can have all what about you
what if you don't cut that should I bite
it like blow did Colombo bite it you
don't want to do that I do want to talk
about arranged marriages for a moment
before we yet before we go on but I
believe in arranged marriages because
all marriages are arranged marriages you
know the reason that arranged marriage
has worked in the past better than
chosen marriages now is because when
your marriage was arranged for you it
was a series of things someone was
selecting on the basis of values and
value and you weren't since you weren't
selecting the person what you were
really opting into was the institution
and the institution of marriage actually
works quite well you know the paultalks
in the New Testament about what a
husband is what a wife is and if you
embrace which it requires sacrifice on
the party on the part of both parties if
you embrace husbanding and you embrace
wifing
those change you and make you better and
create an institution so people were
leaning into that institution
historically not into you know the more
superficial notions but really anyone
who is successfully married today is in
an arranged marriage the marriage was
arranged by the person that they were -
the person that their spouse was and one
of the problems with treating your
spouse like a commodity is it sort of
presumes that the person you pick will
be frozen in time and that is the person
to whom you will be married tomorrow but
if you look at your own life you are not
today the person you were yesterday not
everybody can afford plastic surgeon is
my age but if you if you look back three
years for if you're like me I look back
five years and I have only the most the
most fleeting connection even to the
person I was in so many ways and you
know I'm nine years now into my mirror
the person I am much different than the
person my spouse married the person she
is much different than the person that I
married and so we I am living in the
arranged marriage of my previous self
well and in that way the only hope for
success in my marriage it's the same
hope of the people who were married for
thousands of years before was just to
lean into the instrument and it is it is
a good point that did I mean the truth
is most people are in arranged marriage
in the sense that somebody fix them up
like oh uh but most of most people met
their wife through some sort of fix up
from somebody some third party and that
usually wasn't just because I think that
there's gonna be some sort of mutual
sexual attraction right usually it's
because you you figured that you're
working in the same milieu that there's
a certain level of values and those
values are gonna outlast that like
everybody's gonna be old and wrinkly and
ugly one day so the value is better last
because otherwise I mean if you're
looking for a hot chick at 85 good luck
to you I mean there and not everybody
can Madeline Albright
or make a billion dollars this true 1
billion dollars than even at 81 you can
get a hot and sexy young wife policy
genius our final sponsor who we're gonna
thank tonight and we we must do it
because it is a fundamentally selfish
affair to sit around with your with your
fellows imbibing fine whiskey and cigars
and we must remember that we're being
supported in this pursuit by the fine
people over at policy change father's
Day is coming up if you're a new dad
then you do have certain obligations to
your children drew is the person in this
room closest to death what do you know
close to death I carry him in my I got
it that nobody wants to think about this
but it's always there it's lingering
over here and people depend on you not
just your kids also sometimes your
parents are depending on you if you
disappear as you know I planned never to
die obviously I think that I think
that's clear just some 150 years old I'm
still here but but eventually it's gonna
happen and you want to make sure that
people are there and policy genius it's
it's so easy you don't have to deal with
those insurance salesmen just go on and
you compare the things online takes a
couple of minutes they don't push
anything on you and you get to pick you
can save a lot of money and you pick the
thing you need and they don't just do
life insurance I've got a policy on
Noel's house and supposed to say that
out loud but it's not exactly there's
double indemnity clause
but the policy genius folks they make it
easy not just to get life insurance but
also health insurance disability
insurance and renter's insurance as well
all you have to do is go to policy
genius comm you can get quotes and apply
in minutes it is indeed that easy you
could do it right now and you should do
it right now or as soon as this is over
you should go and because rates are
their lowest in 20 years then you are
going to be getting a great seal go-to
policy genius.com it is indeed the easy
way to compare and buy life insurance go
check it out right now policy genius
Takami oh it's your family not to leave
them in the lurch when you plotz
genius and one of the things that is
absolutely true people sometimes write
in and ask us questions about our
sponsors on on all of the shows over at
the Daily wire you guys obviously do use
these funds we do and not only that not
only that a word of praise for the
god-king we have never been forced to
take a sponsor we had any qualms about
ever it's true yes all praise the God
came here from Elisha I know that there
been people writing in questions for the
panel if you have questions for zou who
just joined us we'd love to hear those
as well Elisha where we got okay so I'm
not sure how logistically this would
work and I don't know if I'm included in
this or not but Raymond hunt comes up
with a pretty interesting idea he says
guys for the next round table can you
please I'll do it from Matt Walsh's car
[Laughter]
we actually invited Matt wolf to join us
because Matt is a father and that seemed
like one of the prerequisites for
everyone on the panel not named Jeremy
or Michael turned us down flat leave
that Carter story he's not gonna come
out of there I could see him though like
he wouldn't hotbox cuz that's on his
style skyping in would would have been
great I mean gosh Rob make that happen
next time Jake that's a much more
serious question he says for everyone on
the panel do you think adopted children
should still try to reconnect with their
biological father so what do you think
about it you know
Shuji I don't know if a person should or
shouldn't you know circumstances are
different I don't think there's a
yes-or-no question to that one you know
it's it's it depends on the circumstance
you know the person's individual
preference I couldn't answer that I
think that's why I agree with that I
think it's a totally individual choice I
think when you're adopted when somebody
raises you when they put their energy
and their money and their time and their
love into you that's your parent that's
the person who is your father or mother
but you might want to know just like
people want to you know spit in a tube
and send their genetics off to a company
and find out who they're related to you
might want to know where you came from
physically and I wouldn't be so quick to
judge you know it's like you know don't
feel like you wouldn't want to reconnect
with him because they abandoned you or
something like that no way they may have
there is a you know at the bottom line
you know that could have gone a whole
other way you know and maybe the person
was just you know in a in a moment of
compassion and say look you know I
really can't do much for you and may had
to I may have been the greatest act of
love they were capable of exam so you
know so it's not casting a judgment I
don't ever want to know them or anything
like that you know yeah and I like what
you said drew because you know I've
always and you see this portrayed again
the culture sometimes lies to us right
because what makes a good story isn't
necessarily what makes good reality but
obviously anytime you watch a show about
an adopted child they always go through
the phase where they turn on the people
who've raised them and look to the
people who who turned them over to be
adopted and and obviously I think that
speaks to something dark in all of us
you know there's something going all the
way back to the Garden of Eden of man
wanting to forsake his own father and
and have the world of his own making
instead of the world that God's actually
placed him in it's a beautiful thing to
to adopt a child you know Nick seriously
who will be with us later today adopted
his son and you know it's the pretty
much the only thing that recommends Nick
Searcy yeah it's a great love that he
has for his son and and and I think is
beautifully reciprocated by the Sun
absolutely I have to differ a little bit
just in thinking obviously everybody's
different people are raised by different
adoptive families and all that I you
know I've got some adopted relatives I
think they're it's that great act of
love of the birth mother to not kill you
in a born and to put you up for adoption
and it's a great act of love for that
family to adopt you and they're your
parents yeah people who adopted you and
raised you as a baby they're your
parents and I think my advice to
people who were adopted is embraced them
as your fam that's your family don't
look back you don't know that's right
all right next question Sarah asks what
advice might you give to a 29 year old
whose father has been an alcoholic and
substance abuser for decades
how can an adult child help a father
that they have outgrown well well I
think I think one of the things that
they teach people who have alcoholic
parents and being a writer at not a lot
of Alcoholics is is they teach you to
detach with love that is you cannot
connect to an alcoholic the way you can
connect to someone who is not an
alcoholic but you don't have to kick
them to the curb yeah so you cannot o
them the things that you would o a
father someone who is addicted to
alcohol or drugs that is their life that
is what they have traded for life they
have traded their lives for that
substance and that's a shame and it's a
terrible thing and you hope that they
can break it because people with God's
help do get out of it but in the
meantime in the meantime you have got to
protect yourself
you have got to protect yourself because
you are the vehicle for the next family
coming up and you're the vehicle for the
future and you've got to say you know I
love you and I'll talk to you but I'm
not going to go down this road with you
and I'm not going to show up every time
you create all the key to what you just
said is with God's help yep people do
break those addictions not with your
help and you are not God and one of the
one of the terrible things that happens
and I think it happens to all of us at
some point especially it plays to the
sort of superficial goodness that we
have from kind of being raised by good
people in a good culture is that we we
sometime times allow that to confuse us
or deceive us into thinking that we are
God and that we can fix people that we
can help people that we can rescue
people from their own choices but you
know our friend I will say his name
because he actually has a job and I say
that he's our friend he may lose that
job we do have a friend who often says
you can't take people scraps for them
and he is a father and I hope you one
day gives that advice to his children
but it's true you can't you can't carry
that kind of a burden for another person
yeah Jeremy and I have a interesting
relationship when business partners for
how long now eight years something like
that almost as long as both of us have
been married we've actually been
business partners which is pathetic but
one of the one of the great differences
between Jeremy of me is I have said this
for a long time
Jeremy's main tendencies as a human
being is when he sees a wounded bird on
the street he wants to pick it up and
nurture it back to health and my main
tendency is to take his head off because
wounded and I think that the happy
medium is probably somewhere in the
middle there you bring it home and you
boil it back to ancient Greece so this
is our final question for this round but
I will be back later with more
subscriber question Zoe asks can you
guys talk about the role that a father
plays in fatherhood that is different
with a boy than a son
yeah or son or and daughters yeah yeah I
noticed that there's no way don't women
have fathers too we don't have any women
on the panel know why she segregated its
going there man women great fathers to
both the mommy and the daddy look how
it's turning out you've got a boy and
you've got a girl exactly the same right
from birth yeah exactly the same I mean
except for you have to be an insane
person to actually think in the society
that says the boys and girls are the
same is the stupidest Society in the
history of mankind anyone who's ever
dealt with small children boys and girls
knows there is a difference okay girls
are sweet and wonderful when they are
small okay they actually can sit and
they can play and they're really nice
and then boys are insane boys are just
suicide machines all they do is try and
run into the street and break their face
on things
and they're nuts there it is true that
what what a father does for for a boy
versus way does for a girl when when
you're a father for a girl you spend
most of your time trying to protect your
girl against and this is true throughout
life I think you spend a lot of time
trying to protect your girl from from
various threats from the outside because
this is the job of a man toward his wife
as well is the job of the man toward his
daughter and for his wife and to warn
your daughter that men are not to be
trifled with right there that men are
can be very threatening right the right
man
can be the best thing in the world for
you there are plenty of terrible guys
out there and it's your job as a dad to
protect your daughters from that for a
son your job is to train your son of you
gentlemen because boys either build or
they destroy there is no in-between from
the time that they are small children
there they're building a tower of blocks
or they are knocking down that tower of
blocks and all they do all day is this
and so if you don't train kids to be a
gentleman boys to be a gentleman they
will turn out to be jerks they'll turn
out to be destructive people women also
to girls I think you know I have three
younger sisters and it seems to me that
one of the big differences between
teenage girls and teenage boys is that
teenage boys this is true for men
generally tend to be destructive of
others right when they when they act out
they tend to lash out at others and hurt
other people they tend to not care about
other people and they tend to hurt other
people girls tend to be self-destructive
they tend to turn it in on themselves
this is why anorexia and bulimia are so
much more common among girls than among
the boys they tend to really be tough on
themselves and so there is a certain
amount of steam building that has to go
into being a dad toward a girl that does
not have to happen with a boy before a
boy it's mostly you keep yourself under
control and this is why you see single
motherhood has an impact on girls but it
has much more of an impact on boys when
there's no father in the home to
actually take care of boys or if there's
no community of fathers right there's a
study that was just done that shows that
the single greatest predictor of teenage
crime is not actually only single
motherhood in a particular home it's
single motherhood in a community so if
there's a community of men around they
can sometimes fill the gap that's left
by a particular father in a particular
community but men have to be there to
model for boys what it is to be a
gentleman and to be a defender of
decency as opposed to being an aggressor
because boys who are not offenders
become aggressors yeah it's important
for a boy to grow to be a gentleman and
I know my father told me I'm sure your
father told you be a gentleman associate
with other gentlemen if there are
certain clubs having just recently had a
bachelor party it's so important to hang
out and gentlemen club this is there's
that great book by Harvey Mansfield
called manliness and he talks just about
this part of manliness and what a father
needs to teach a boy is manliness is
being a gentleman
you know after basically after Nietzsche
after God is dead
manliness can go pretty wrong it can get
pretty wild it's kind of what they talk
about on the left o'clock master
but they they label all masculine any
tax exactly man looks at a woman and
she's pretty oh it's toxic masculine and
also the way human beings appropriated
for the last several hundred thousand
here but it is there is a there is a
destructive part of manliness and it's
got to be restrained by being a
gentleman if you don't teach your boy to
be a gentleman he's gonna grow up and be
a little monster but even at the same
time though when we talk about being
gentlemanly or being a man being a man
according to what though that's the
problem because we could talk about
being a man all day but what does that
actually mean what does that really look
like or being a gentleman how you gonna
cheat a woman and stuff like that
because we're gonna have different
standards and different models of what
that looks like and and all of those
things they they're they don't really
have a solid foundation so to that end
what do we look towards to be a model
man a model gentleman a model father a
model husband you know what do we look
to I mean for myself you know I think
people would know that my answer is
gonna be the scriptures I look to the
Bible exactly I look towards him and I
look at his statutes on how to do that
but I think that's one of the bigger
problems is that that's one of the
things that's promoted you know it's
like you got to be a man okay a man
according to what you know so unless we
really get solid with that a lot of
people reject what the truth is on that
and that's another problem
one of the interesting things that God
did is that he he sort of condescend it
even in language so that we could
comprehend him right because what God is
we can't understand
and so God God calls himself a father
not and we look at that wrong we look at
our fathers at the beginning of wisdom
as you look at your father and try to
understand something about God the
greater truth is that you look at God
and you learn something about being a
father right or about having I thought
that's that's why it's at the top of the
list I you know and God the Lord your
God let's get that straight first right
you know this it's it's such a truth
it's such a high truth it's basically a
law there is no truth higher than that
you know and then from there when he
goes on to talk about honoring your
father and honoring your mother it's
like look you gotta honor me first
you tryin to honor your father and your
mother you tryin to be right by
everybody else you're gonna get it wrong
your love sucks all right love you so
let people think that God is like some
megalomaniac fathers I just love me love
me is like no no no my love will hurt
you to hurt you to hurt you it hurt my
wife would hurt my mama hurt everybody
but if I filter that through God and
understand and go buy a statue it's in
the goatee
to learn how to do this then I will
understand what it is to know cuz we
like how do you honored like you were
asking earlier like you know about you
know father being an alcoholic you know
how do you honor a person like that you
know it's like well my father my mother
they weren't there for me they were this
they were that how do I honor them
well you honor them by being the kind of
person that a mother and that a father
and mother should honor right at least a
halfway well-adjusted person should
honor that's what you do oh and then you
learn about it just like with the father
if God being loved as it says in John
the Epistle you the first step of wisdom
is to understand God because of having
experienced love but the greater step is
to understand love because of God that
God is not our love but that our love
should reflect indeed you know there's
another aspect I agree with everything
you guys are saying and but we're
talking a lot about training and
teaching and one of the things that a
father does this most important is
represent because a woman a woman is
defined in a lot of ways by her body if
you can have a child you are a woman you
know there's a lot of other things that
go into it I you know lady but it's just
true you know but a man and a man is an
abstraction manliness is an abstraction
you got to see it
you got to be there you got to smell it
and one of the things about absent
fathers is you can't smell it me I can't
see them and when you talk about you
know children boys especially learn and
communicate through objects girls talk
men play catch men play video games they
sit around and that is how they
communicate because it's all about
seeing the thing there and when you talk
about God God sent us somebody we could
see if somebody with flesh on that you
can look at the sequel right I think you
know it's just when fathers leave man
they take away it's like taking the son
away from a plant it takes away the
thing that you grow toward and all the
other stuff is true the teaching and the
rules and the control but most important
is showing well this is why is it so
funny whenever you hear people in the me
to movement say teach boys not to rape
like how many people in this room I
assume nobody in this room is rapists
right so and if you are don't say it
as a criminal and I have to report you
or do say and I'll go reporting but in
any case I you know nobody and I assume
none of your father set you down and
said boys don't rain blood of Krait
because that's absurd
well your father did instead is modeled
the decent behavior and made it clear
that the expectation was that you were
going to protect women this is the thing
that you were going to do you were going
to protect women I do wonder whether our
culture now since we've leveled out the
sexes you know the the the the schtick
on the Titanic which is this the ship is
going down and now we're going to get
the women and children off first I
wonder if our society would do that
anymore
no way when you say women and men are
the same then then you've really
mitigated the crime of rape because if
women are like men they just want to
have sex all the time
only if women are different than men
only if women need to be protected by by
the strength of good men is there a
crime to this sort of lack of concern
I'm not saying that men can't be raped
but I'm saying that that is the right
extreme minority of a lot of corollaries
come from this too because you can read
you know when you talk about recruiting
people into the cult of parenthood
you can read about this all you want but
children touch play every key on your
piece exactly so if you are not in some
way right with yourself and with God if
you're not some way adjusted and put
together they are gonna find that place
before we continue I want to let Alicia
go so she can get some more questions
well Alicia thank you so much for those
great questions see if you if you're
watching at home you'll want to get a
few questions in we are gonna answer a
few more during the course of the
broadcast but you must first subscribe
over at daily wired.com become a premium
subscriber either monthly or annual
although we strongly recommend annual
not only because it ensures that we get
more of your delicious delicious math
money but it also ensures you get they
left us tears hot or cold tumblr it's
also time to say goodbye this oh but
instead of that though can you hang with
us for one more segment I'm loving have
you don't wanna I don't you got a lot
more Stoke there are cigars don't it is
also time for us to thank another
sponsor that is helix sleep and Ben
since you have the helix helix man you
are the man it is great the pillow
that's right
new mattresses are just tremendous they
are made directly for you the way this
works you go to helix sleep calm and
they have this two-minute sleep quiz it
asks you whether you like to sleep on
your side or on your back and if you how
your body is structure do you like the
mattress to be soft you'd like it to be
firm they can even make the mattress so
that it differs between the sides of the
mattress for you and your spouse now
that we've recruited you into the cult
of marriage and and it's really
important to because you know people
liked it like you know I'm recently
married to sweet little Lisa and so I
like a mattress that's more firm you
know and she likes a mattress that I'm
not on can make that happen for you if
you get rid of Knowles for me I mean I
was the great thing about helix sleep is
that again it is customized for you
comes in the mail yun packet it actually
inflates right in front of you because
it's foam and you throw it on bed and
you are ready to go and for Father's Day
right now you can go to helix sleep calm
/ bed and get up to 125 bucks toward
your mattress order again that's helix
sleep calm / men and you get to 125
dollars toward that mattress order it's
again the most comfortable and first
I've slept on we took a more expensive
mattress and actually moved it out of
the room because this is a better
mattress helix sleep calm / Ben for your
hundred and twenty-five bucks off and
it's a perfect Father's Day gift it's
really excellent check it out he looks
like calm / Ben that's awesome and Ben
before we cut to the ED you're getting
ready to say something profound I'm a
pretty good judge like drew will start
to say something about the disconnects
that people seem to have between also
their daughters and how they treat women
so what you I think one of the things
that you're talking about is how you
know having kids changes you when you
have a daughter you see this with a lot
of men it's on the new Kanye album which
I've apparently now been forced to
listen to because Kanye's pro-trump and
that means that we almost listen to
Kanye West
apparently not my cup of tea but his new
album has a whole song on there about
how he has a new daughter and now it's
changed his perspective on me - that's
right after the song where he talks
about how he has a two eyes and
therefore women have two breasts it
hasn't completely permeated his
worldview yet I think but nonetheless it
is true that all these guys who will
treat women like dirt like grown women
like dirt
the minute they have a daughter they
realize that if a man treated their
daughter like that they would murder
that that human being well these are
fatherly advice your father gave right
yep and it you know it matters too I
mean when you talk about being an
example you're also being an example to
your daughter of what a man is like this
is which is why I always tell people the
first thing is be good to your wife
because that is bad it's gonna mean
everything to your so many women they
have the fathers who are bad then they
end up with men who are bad because
they're people peoples gonna marry their
parents it's very weird you know they
don't know I mean they don't know that
they can expand I really the only people
can get past that I don't believe we're
locked into this Freudian circle but you
got to be careful if your father was a
bad guy you got to be careful not to
imitate that no you're you're a father
to a daughter what's that
how do you navigate that I have cats
because I'm like thinking I mean and I'm
glad to be here but also how did I get
better presa I don't have any kids and
my dad wasn't really involved it's
played up a lot you know we see the ads
you know don't forget to be a father
today yeah yeah you know and it's like
no no don't forget to be a husband you
know the best thing is like because we
hear all the time you know the most
important thing in my life for my kids
made my kids whether they you're
separating or whether they're together
it's like no no the most important
person in your life is supposed to be
your spouse you know actually I mean
really the most important person is
supposed to be a life is the Lord
Himself who teaches you how to love your
spouse like I was saying earlier my love
will hurt my spouse so I don't dare try
to love her on my own accord
I go to I go to the Lord to learn how to
love her right you know the Lord who
says hey you need to love her like it
I'd lay down my life for my church I'll
lay down my life for you you know and of
course I'm no good to my wife dead you
know but you know but at the same time
you genius actually good question I
think I think um you know since some of
us all of us are married but only two of
us have kids so if you what what is your
priority right if you have to choose
like is it is it wife or is it kids like
what's your what is your first priority
because people tend to build their lives
around this specific question my view
has always been the
the whole purpose of marriage is the
procreation and raising of the children
in the end like if you have to boil down
marriage to it societal impact while
it's great for people who are married
the difference between in my view
traditional marriage and same-sex
marriage for example is that there are
certain marriages to produce children
and the whole reason that God cares
whether you marry another human being as
opposed to just sleeping and staying in
a relationship with another human being
is even lock yourself in for the benefit
of those children and if you have your
mind on that then it's better but you
know I could see that that argument he
made the other way and no dr. Laurel
always just make the argument the other
way that your spouse is your first
priority in your kids are your second
priority I tend to think the opposite
maybe because my dad raised me this way
the kids are the first priority and your
spouse an adult so your spouse's is sort
of second priority how do you how do you
view that one I don't I don't actually
think I can I think the question is not
phrased in a way that can actually
answer it because the way I feel about
parents is that they are their
children's world I frequently see people
get divorced for bad reasons with young
kids and they say oh the kids are fine
and I think yeah the kids are fine you
just blew up their planet I just beat up
their planet so you have to tend that
planet for them to live on I mean that
is the thing so you can say the kids are
coming first but in order for the kids
to come first the wife has to come first
I mean another way it's a copy of that
marriage model and it has got to be a
great place for them to live and it's
got to be a place where they again where
they see the values taking place and I
see everything happening the way it's
supposed to happen yeah like so many
things I've heard it I've heard
something stated in a way that I
believed it was true and something the
very same thing but stated differently
and thus I believe it is false
my aunt once told me that you have to
love your spouse more than your children
she said you know if one of my children
was drowning and my spouse was drowning
I would save my spouse and what and and
it bothered me at the time because I was
quite young and I thought you know I was
the center of the universe kids are the
center of the universe what I came to
realize is that part of what she's
saying is that you you actually you you
so owe your children the planet that it
is but you know because she had other
children and what's you know she's not
saying what I save all of my children
but I think what she's saying is my
children need a father they they need a
father so much that it is worth saving
my father for my other children even at
that expense and that's such an
unpopular sentiment now that we rejected
but how she phrased it to me was hey
save your dog and you let everyone
on another occasion a close friend of
mine her father said to her sister in a
time of struggle you know I can have
other children but I'm the only father
you will ever have and he's saying
something that is mathematically equal
to what my aunt said the difference is
my aunt and my uncle are fabulous
parents and and have raised wonderful
children and this particular father if
we ever encounter him as a group cuz
none of us are very strong individually
but as a group we would most certainly
murder him and then we would all get
together from the next cigar show and
what kind of occur to me like halfway
through like what you guys remember when
we murder the key right when you're
saying to you do you prefer your child
or do you prefer your spouse not having
a child I can only think that the answer
to that is you prefer your children in
the preference of your spouse it's not a
one or that's right it's a that's being
a good husband is the prerequisite to
being a great father is the best way to
show your value for your kids is to show
the values for your spouse that's that's
what's really as we look at it I mean
with the divorce rate and the way
relationships are now you just see you
know generations coming up and these
these these cats are like broken they're
they're so insecure and we wonder why
people melt down so easily well because
their parental units melted down you
know and you see people that don't want
to take responsibility for nothing they
don't they're ready to cast blame well
they learn that from their folks they
don't want to take responsibility for
the dissolution of their marriage and
they cast blame on each other wait think
I learned that from you know so it's
like look and I hear and I hear people
who are you know are no longer in their
marriage anymore and they talk about how
much they love their kids and stuff like
this so why don't you have that grace
for the the person you created the kids
with we're all that patience and all
that acceptance and all this that love
that you want to pour into your kids
really it's the self righteous guys
really you're trying to redeem yourself
or up somehow for how much you love your
children
where was that grace for your spouse
yeah you know show that and in and I've
look I would I would posture that our
generations would let the whole
different we would have more solid
people we would have all these
snowflakes they're just melting down so
easily if they come to grips with that
well there is you know now in the
culture they're all these false
dichotomies so we redefined marriage and
you we say well I love my spouse so much
I love this life I don't want to have
kids I'd I just don't want to do it I
want and having been recently through a
Catholic marriage ceremony they're very
pro kids life and there was this old
unity of the idea right this unity of
the family I love my spouse I am open to
life if you say that you're not open to
having kids that that Catholic Church I
think I'm the soul papist on the panel
they will not give you a marriage
license yeah not everybody gets to have
kids a lot of people can't have kids but
the openness to it is that unity though
if you if you're open to life you're
gonna love your spouse more if you love
you but you know it's it's that one
thing to say that they're opposed is
crazy
is that people see them they think they
love their child because they see
themselves in their child but they hate
their spouse for the same reason you
know this is this is though what we're
really talking about all this owns an
entire conversation the great Jewish
toast look I am yeah we are actually
talking about life
you know being open to life being open
to the procreation of life the
continuation of life the dedication to
life throws life its pro-life this is
also what makes you know politics
important so in our normal day jobs
we're all talking about politics in that
fatherhood but this is why I think that
politics actually is important because
otherwise if you're not talking about
what you're doing for the next
generation what you're doing for your
kids and how you raise those kids then
what the hell are you talking Tex has
become not about that right we won't
even talk about the ones that are like
the most basic the there are certain
basic issues that obviously affect our
children and we refuse to talk about
them because we're such a selfish people
at this point obviously you know the
breakdown of the entitlement programs
that all of our kids are gonna have to
pay for but we don't give a crap about
it because the baby boomer generation
wants its money and we want our money
and that means that our kids are gonna
have to pay for that or whether it comes
to there's this there's this tremendous
lack of self-confidence and how to
educate our children that's happening
right now I'm not gonna put my values on
my kid because if I put my values on my
kid and that's me imposing my worldview
on my kid and how could I possibly
impose my worldview on my kid look a
worldview is going to get imposed on
your kid because your kid is not capable
of making decisions which means that
it's up to you now you need to decide
what you believe
and this is one of the things that when
you're parents I think when you first
have kids it is true when you're married
to a certain extent because you'll
figure out whether you have common
values with your spouse which is why I
always say don't date insert politically
into religiously or intra values wise I
think generally speaking you should be
dating people who I'm sure about it
gives you the best odds of success some
some of these other things work but the
best odds of success you're dating
someone who has the same values once you
have kids then whatever you thought that
your giant kind of panoply of values was
has to narrow down to the values you are
willing to teach your kids what are
these what's the set of values that
you're going to teach your kids and this
is sort of been my interpretation over
the most bizarre you guys got into talk
a lot in New Testament so bear with me
[Laughter]
the most puzzling aspect of the of the
Old Testament obviously is the sacrifice
of Isaac which everyone has puzzled over
for generations and kirkegaard came up
with the idea of the the teleological
leap beyond beyond reason in all of us
but I think that the what that story is
really trying to say is not that God
wants you know your child who died in an
altar I think what that story is really
trying to say is to put it in the Jewish
context when I decide to raise my kid
Jewish I'm making a specific decision to
put my child at risk and when I was in
law school there was a guy who I was who
I was going to law school with and it
was Mike and a Jewish guy and he said
specifically he did not want to get
married to a Jewish person and raise his
kid Jewish because he said the single
greatest risk factor I can add to that
kid's life is making that kid Jewish
considering the amount of anti-semitism
in the world so why not just remove out
of it and then I don't have to worry
about it anymore which is not the worst
logic right I mean if you actually want
to protect your child if your chief goal
in life is to protect your child you're
gonna bring your child up in the way
that is least likely to put them in a
risky situation they don't have to stand
for anything because standing for things
means you're also most likely to get
knocked down well I think that what the
sacrifice of Isaac really is saying when
you read the story is pretty clear
actually is it God is saying are you
willing to sacrifice your child to me
not in the sense like I want you to kill
your child are you willing to heighten
the risk factor for your child's life by
teaching them values that put them more
at risk in the world and standing for
things makes you more at risk in the
world standing for things makes you more
likely to become the target of people
who don't like your value system and so
when in the easy way in America in a
free country the easiest way to
bring up your kids it's a no value
system and I'll go to public school and
buy whatever you buy from the culture
we'll all get along and all be great but
that doesn't create the Warriors
necessary to defend the Western
civilization that's going to promote the
possibility of a further generation
because that line runs out pretty darn
quickly and so we have to decide all of
us as you know parents and prospective
parents what are the values that you
want to pass down to your child and you
have to have the self confidence and in
my view the scriptural confidence to say
these are the values that are worthy of
passing down to my child and worthy of
me making my child's life more risky and
I can tell you by the way just as
somebody there's older children grown
children that the proudest moments in
your life the best moments in your life
are those moments when your children
turn to the wave of culture and say no
I'm not gonna do it I'm doing it the
right way when that happens to you just
think like little kids do the right
thing yep it's an amazing music an
amazing thing the other day my daughter
did something wrong and she she lied I
said and I said sweetheart you're not
allowed to lie you're just and you're
not allowed to lie I'm upset at you
because you lied and she started crying
because she felt guilty and then she
said daddy I love you I'm never gonna
lie again and then she wouldn't get off
it like for a while she was really like
very upset that she alleged that I'm so
embed I'm embarrassed that I lied she's
very smart for a four-year-old and she
and she and I thought now this is a good
thing I'm creating a good person here
right I'm partnering with God and my
wife in the creation of a better human
being not just in the inception of this
human being but in the raising of this
human being you become partners with God
and raising your child and if you don't
take that partnership seriously then you
know to put the kid who doesn't have a
God and doesn't have a childhood doesn't
haven't adulthood and she feels guilty
in front of you because you modeled that
- right exactly
he knows that yeah and what better way
to facilitate somebody you know when
we're talking about you know a child
should be able to make their own
decisions stuff like that yeah I I agree
but just like anything else don't you
want to give them something foundational
don't you want to have them to have like
a level you know a level foundation and
a clear perspective on how to make
decisions for themselves it's not
imposed it's like look I'm not gonna
take this Bible I'm gonna beat you over
the head with it it's my responsibility
to make sure that you understand what it
is to make the choice like hey when you
had that you know the situation with
with Adam and II Old Testament it have
been nice if God if Adam would have
sought the counsel of God you know so
you got at it hey pops you know um
see the snake is trying to push up on my
woman right now I'm not quite sure
because he's right there you know he's
standing right there and he has no
excuse not to seek the counsel of God to
understand what it is that he's supposed
to do you know he doing steady hides in
the bushes but you know but there was no
excuse for that and you know even in
speaking of you know a Father's Day they
what-what greater story between a father
and a son and and his bride now cuz
we're talking about you know the bride
you know the one who said that you know
speaking of Isaac you know Abraham and
speaking of father in the Sun in the
sacrifices that are made the sacrifice
to show the love for the son the show of
the show of love for the father and the
show of love for the bride I mean this
all plays in and this is something there
is there's a lapse somewhere in the
culture of where this is missing where
we're supposed to line up but where our
priorities in love are supposed to be so
you know a man and a woman and their
children it's why the first great gift
you can give to your children is to
model being a father and husband and
that's the answer to your question from
a minute ago if God is father and
husband you can not maybe not you can't
it will be much harder for you to pass
the values of monotheism of Judaism and
Christianity on to your child if you
have not first modeled for them what it
even is to be a good father second
secondary gifts that is to say no to
your kid as Judaism he points to him and
he says Christianity points
so you and me get the seat warm for
brother Nick the International film and
television star somebody's gonna
certainly come help me so with that and
I'll use this moment to say if you are
not a subscriber over at the daily wire
if you are not giving us your sweet
sweet money on a monthly or annual basis
to me the shekels never there are things
you are missing among which are being
able to write to Alicia Krause over in
the green room and ask questions of the
panel if you have questions on
fatherhood if you have questions on what
it means to be a husband what it means
be a man in today's world if you just
want to share with us some story about
the advice that your father may have
given to you I think your your chance is
now we're gonna take questions one more
time again daily wire comm become a
subscriber get the leftist tears hot or
cold tumblr get the live broadcast of
dementia Piro show the Andrew Clavin
show the Michael Knowles show also
access to all of our back catalogue ask
questions during the conversation it's a
is it worth it yes and you know one of
the as we've talked about all of these
things today I've I've got a real sense
of gratitude toward my parents and I
then I know you do too for enduring the
difficulties of marriage on our behalf
because it's at the end of the day you
know the own children aren't the only
reason you can have a successful
marriage but I think I think that in
most instances children are are part of
the glue that keeps that keeps marriage
as healthy and functioning and they're
also an obstacle I mean let's be real
about this dads do make marriage harder
I mean there's there's no question that
you lose more time they have to spend
more time there's more stress you're
more stressed out I mean you're more
tired there's it these are these are
just things that happen when you have
kids and it should make you more
grateful one of the big things is is
making sure that you're more grateful to
your spouse for helping you out with
this burden as opposed to angry at your
spouse for for having to you know do
things that you don't want to do right
now it's it is a glue that holds it kids
are our glue that hold families together
but they can also be a real divisive
force if you are not willing to
acknowledge what it is that your spouse
is doing for you and also if you are not
willing to see when you're wrong like
it's you know the old joke is that you
know the first words that you should say
when you wake up in the morning your
wife as I'm sorry I just get out of the
way but it but it is true that I think
that what makes you a better human being
in regards to marriages is recognizing
when you're wrong it's a hard thing to
do especially when you're tired and
you're grumpy to stop for a second and
just say is there a point here like is
it really from being a jerk because
sometimes you really are being a jerk
and if you can do that then I think that
that's also something else to model for
kids because kids need to learn to say
that they are wrong if kids never
believe they're wrong the self-esteem
movement has done more damage to
children than any other thing that's
happened over the last 50 years in this
whole idea that you're supposed to
express your emotions I think we we
probably agree on this ya know emotions
you don't have emotions but when if
you're annoying British approach you can
have a modem down into a beautiful
stomach ulcer but it's a good thing to
be able to say to your wife I'm annoyed
without saying you stupid a life with
another human being another adult human
being and you don't grant them the
freedom to criticize you right if you
don't then you're not allowing part of
what God gives us in marriage is a
mirror by which we get to see our own
faults and flaws through the pain that
that may it's a horrible it's not
horrible it's beautiful but it's tragic
that we we see our rough spots through
the damage that they can sometimes
inflict on this person who we love who
were who were making decisions with who
is in this battle with us and it's
through that that we learn the places
the places that we need to make
improvements in ourself if you don't
grant your spouse that that freedom when
you're saying what you think you're
perfect you really do well you're saying
who you think you're perfect in your
marry and you realize how screwed up you
are it's good for you it's actually good
frame you can be perfect as long as
women don't fly and swim into your can I
think men can be absolutely perfect as
long as there are no women names the
minute minute women show up you think
like oh I get it I stink so we have Nick
Searcy is about to join us in I I just
gotta tell you guys nervous I know it
was nervous yeah because there's an
internationals there are stars yeah
there are film stars right there there's
Ella vision stars there are national
international stars there are Academy
award-winning stars yeah there are far
fewer statistically yeah Peabody
award-winning start and I'm going to
tell you guys a story about Nick before
he comes in for those who don't know
Nick Nick mix a better guy than he wants
you to think that he is but but Nick is
in every oscar-nominated film every
oscar-nominated film of the last year
Nick it's the modesty's I think that
really this is a true story about Nick
and they're gonna come help Nick it Mack
miked up and plugged in but Nick and I
were together when we
first encountered Donald Trump and now I
have known I've known Nick Searcy for
quite some time been an admirer because
he leaves you really no option but to be
[Laughter]
and Nick is a shameless self-promoter
and there we were sitting at an event
that we were hosting and the future
president of united states walks in to
give one of his first political speeches
like this is like seven or ten days
after he announces for the presidency
and no stand-up comedy show I've ever
been to compares oh he was much funnier
then because it was shocking Marianas it
was the funniest thing I've ever seen
and I looked over at Nick halfway
through this and I thought you have
faded it's like he is three he is three
times the Nick Searcy that you are it's
like that they took my acting school
thanks for hanging out with us you know
yes I do
we have for you a limited edition Romeo
and Juliet straight from slave island
brought back with our own hands up
brought back with our own damn yes this
is great yeah amazing oh this is great
thank you
if you don't like it blame druggie
Pinkett well the best part of that
Donald Trump thing is that I had I I
wasn't even gonna go cuz I thought this
guy's a joke I don't see this but you
know he said that thing and then we're
not on you right thing that said you
know it's gonna be kind of protest
outside so you might be a good idea to
take an uber or something yeah
and so as five hundred protesters
outside her event helicopters overhead
and so I Mark and I decided to go but I
decided to wear my Lucha Libre wrestling
mask so I had like a white suit Libre
mask and we went by the protesters and
they were outside going we are man
Teredo Trump is racist you know and they
see me and they go Lucha Libre screamin
and I'm doing this
some media comes up with a microphone
and goes why are you wearing a mask I go
I'm this is a top-secret organization
also mink Searcy Nick Searcy comm acting
school by Niki receive because he
doesn't not one time as anybody asked
Nick why he's doing something and he
said it's a secret I don't know what
we're talking about fatherhood we're
talking about being a husband being a
man because obviously it's Father's Day
I actually told a story about you before
you got here it was it was Jonas it was
generous the kind of thing I'm very
strange I don't trust them but you you
occupy a unique space because you're the
only person that we're talking to
tonight who has adopted a son and we we
talked a little bit about it in your
absence but I'd love to just hear your
perspective on what it is to be father
to a child that you chose I mean that's
a unique that's a unique situation yeah
well it was unique I mean we had we have
a daughter Chloe who's 28 and grown and
and you know oh they're older than your
son
yes she's 28 war zone yeah um but that
sort of how it came about is that Leslie
now we're wanting to have another child
and we you know tried some various
things and you know not to go into
detail but you know for whatever reason
and so you know we were talking one
night and Leslie was like why do you why
do you think you want another child you
know I said well honestly I guess I
guess having had the experience of
raising a girl I would like to try to
have the experience of raising a boy too
and Leslie said well you know there's no
guarantee that if I got pregnant it
would be a boy so why don't we just go
adopt one mm-hmm
that made sense and my daughter brought
home a thing from school that you know
had child's social services number on it
said every child needs a home and Chloe
handed it to us and said you know they
do you know Chloe's about 11 so we went
through the process and just became
foster parents we decided we wanted to
adopt out of the foster care system and
you know that's just kind of how came
about and we got qualified to be foster
parents and then immediately when you
get qualified they just start calling
you up and no matter what you told them
you wanted there like one you know we've
got triplets here that you know and so
we we met a you know number of
situations that you know we're kind of
heartbreaking but sort of wrong for us
you know and my wife was looking for a
child that was five years old so that it
would go to school the next year but we
we met Omar who was with a family that
he'd been with since he was two weeks
old I think and that family was leaving
the state and he couldn't go back to his
birth family so he had to be moved and
when we met him you know always told my
wife I always tell everybody it was like
the most direct experience with God that
I think I've ever felt because the
minute I laid eyes on Omar I knew that
he was supposed to be with me I just
knew he was my son
and so he was 15 months old you know
just graduate from high school and now
we're taking him to college and in July
yeah he's gonna play basketball at wake
Technical College in Raleigh North
Carolina and I'm moving to North
Carolina for basketball season will be
privileged to have an international film
star and yeah I graciously told my wife
that she could move with me she comes
first you know so was there is there a
some kind of difference between raising
your child that you adopted and raising
your child that you had biological yeah
I mean yes there is I mean you know when
you have a biological child you kind of
there are certain things that you just
sort of instinctively know about them
because they're part of your flesh and
blood or something you know they inherit
things from you they inherit traits from
you they their looks their personalities
oh that's just like your mom you know
whatever yeah but when you adopt a child
he comes with his own set of things that
he's inherited that you so like you know
for the you know for his whole life you
just go okay where the hell is that
coming
you know but but in terms of like you
know the sort of feeling that you have
for them I don't think there's a
difference I mean you know we love them
our and been in love with him since he
was baby but he's he's been sort of a
mystery here he doesn't have any of our
traits inherited and he's got his own
set yeah is it there's a weird question
that is writ really only applies to you
and me yours that when you live your
life in the arts there's a certain
amount of self involvement that just
comes with the profession I know you
would never be it just anymore I
understand but as an international films
I know you're an international film star
because I read it on your Twitter feed
[Laughter]
in being a father well yes and no I mean
yeah you you do have a tendency
sometimes to get kind of wrapped up in
your own in your own head and your own
activities but on the other hand your
home a lot I mean I remember my daughter
had you know career day at school when
she was in kindergarten and the other
kids were like going my dad's a fireman
and my dad you know he works at the
hospital and well he goes I don't know
what he does yeah yeah you do have it
and my wife reminds me of that has
reminded me of that many times over the
years and a very colorful way having my
head somewhere that it shouldn't be yeah
we're gonna take our last round of
questions from subscribers over at Daily
wire calm these are the privileged few
through our our monthly and annual
subscribers you get to write in and ask
questions of the panel Alicia what do we
got oh we have a very important question
here Luke says Ben speaking of fathers
is your father's daughter in law a
doctor that is that is the rumor rumor
is that she is in fact doctor I would
never talk about such things it's like
somebody who'd never talk
being an international film about my
wife being a physician in family
medicine and being in school forever
never ever getting out of residency ever
on this the fastest grow the biggest and
fastest growing podcast my favorite part
of posting the conversations with Ben is
to see how many of those questions come
in we're definitely going to have to at
some point have my wife on like the
Sunday conversation yes all the women in
the office are very excited about this
just to see her just destroy me on air
here on destroy Shapiro and then in a
few years we'll have your oldest child
on and she will also do the same yeah so
moving on a more serious question Jacob
asks a really good one this is
specifically for Ben how involved should
a dad be in their child's social and
academic life how thin is the line
between being a helicopter parent or a
deadbeat dad so you know the truth is
that drew is is sometimes better you
know position to answer some of these
because kids are older you know for for
me my view is that when it comes to
social life you got to make sure your
kids are not hanging out with bad people
which means that you have to have a
really good handle on who your kids are
hanging out with a lot of that comes
through school choice in the community
you choose to cultivate and the people
you're hanging out with so keep keeping
your kids away from bad influences I
think requires a certain amount of
helicopter parenting when it comes to
academics the hardest thing is allowing
your kid to fail and you know I think
that the it really is a factor of effort
so what we've been trying to teach my
daughter is that it's not a matter of
what you accomplish it's a matter of the
effort that you're putting in because if
you praise the accomplishment then they
get used to the accomplishment then when
they fail then they get really upset and
they destroy themselves whereas if you
praise the effort while the effort is
always just a factor of how hard they're
trying that's the only thing I can
control anyway because if you're trying
as hard as you can you can't control
anything beyond that so what that really
means is that in terms of academics I'm
very involved with my daughter in terms
of reading books to her and teaching her
how to read right now and all that but
once she gets to a certain point I want
to help her enough that she has the
tools so that she can do the work but
then I want to leave her to her own
devices to actually actually succeed or
fail it Ray's long relation for for
Nichkhun and drew
which is because you have adult children
now what what obligation does the father
have to turn loose of the child and to
let them become their own purse it's the
whole obligation is exactly what you're
trying to do is let that now become
himself at herself and be free but it's
not helicopter parenting to pay
attention to the kids social life and to
pay attention to the kids academic life
its helicopter parenting never to let
the child fail and say or risk
that's helicopter parenting and that I
think is a smothering I know it's not
the same thing I noticed this with both
of my parents because I think it's
easier for the father to you know the
father is not probably going to be
baking cupcakes and going to you know
every PTA meeting or something but both
of my parents were always aware they
were aware of things I did not know they
were aware of they were always very but
they weren't inserting themselves all
the time in all this little I think that
that's the real key because I would see
I'm not an international film and
television I've been going on these
little auditions or doing a little thing
as a teenager or something I'd see these
poor kids with these stage mothers and
these you know stage father's sometimes
hovering constantly and everything and
it just destroys that's the biggest
thing is not living out your own
ambitions through your kids that one is
really tough and I mean having that as a
four with the boy robbing the
two-year-old saying well I would love
for you to do this well maybe my kid
doesn't want to do that or make it isn't
qualified to do that maybe they're
qualified to do something else yeah yeah
huge you know although I remember
talking to your daughter telling me how
you would you liked the idea for
becoming an actor whereas I would have
like laid my body down my wife and I are
just you know she's my wife's a dancer
and an actress and Chloe I remember she
came home from college one time and said
you know I'm thinking about maybe coming
up going to law school and Leslie now
we're like what so boring no daughter of
mine is gonna be a writer
but also about the academics you know
it's sort of we had totally different
experiences with Chloe I don't think we
ever spoke to her but on her homework
her whole life you know she did I got
this you know she was just on top of it
all the time and so and you know she was
great she was a great student with Omar
we were just like buddy you got a C it's
like you know you just take them where
they are and as long as they're making
the effort that they need to be making
and you know then that's on a kind of
boys and girls being exactly the same
yeah yeah unlike as Nick said you know
their kids go into acting know it's easy
go into it don't be like Nick is
generally good advice right because you
can't speaking of those kids Susan asks
hey guys this is to everyone what do you
think about women who have been divorced
but have kids in terms of what's best
for the kids
should they try to remarry I have an
opinion about this actually mature me
you have an opinion about every sound of
one hand clapping I think that there's a
real age age of the child question which
is that if you have a child who is very
very young newborn 1 2 3 I think it's
the obligation of the mother but let's
put divorce aside and think maybe the
the father passed away because it takes
out some of the complications if maybe
there's a bad father out there somewhere
I think there's a certain obligation on
the part of the wife to at least try to
remarry in in the period when the child
is still young enough that having a
father is going to is going to be part
of their foundational sort of
understanding of the world however if if
the child is let's say 13 one of the
hard ages 11 12 13 I actually think that
there's the opposite obligation it's
incumbent on the parent not to remarry
during that period of time when what
you're going to thrust into the child
and the hardest years of their life is
confusion and competition for the
affection of the parent
that remains and then once the child is
grown now it's incumbent on the parent
to pursue their own fulfillment in
whichever direction that takes them and
even if it offends the child because the
20 year old child or the 21 or 22 year
old child may still struggle with the
fact that mom is now dating another man
but at that point part of what you have
to model for the child is the pursuit of
marriage the pursuit of of fulfillment
and finer things for yourself and that
the world isn't you know but now that
they're an adult they can't have all of
you in the same way that they've
formerly had all of you what do you guys
think
yeah I'm listen as the sole papist again
in the room I'm very anti divorce yeah
and I really I benefited you know in a
way because the divorce of my parents
happened when I was so so young my
mother didn't remarry she didn't really
date in my recollection at all really my
father did remarry that worked out fine
but I had functionally my parents yeah
saw them everyday and lived with my
mother saw my father every day and
that's the reason it worked I mean
that's I really when I think back if my
mother had dated or remarried I really
think there's a great deal of wisdom and
to millennia of a church saying don't
you dare divorce don't you remarry
there's a big debate now going on in the
Catholic Church can civilly remarried
people receive the Eucharist and all of
that and the traditional people are
saying no there were all of these
external effects that can really screw
up a kid and though and those are the
victims of it you know they're the
they're five years old so they can't
really say they're the victims of it but
there is a real cost to them Jeremy I
think I think it basically right but I
think that just to make it a little bit
more general I think that the real
question is are you getting remarried
for the benefit of the child are you
getting remarried for the benefit of you
and if you're getting remarried for the
benefit the child even if it's a
troubled ten-year-old who needs a father
in the home to actually crack the whip
then it seems more acceptable to me but
if you're just doing it because you're
lonely and because you're having a
problem then your kids at that point
your first priority is making sure that
your kids grow up healthy not not your
own happiness and all of our opinions on
anything like this are kind of
generalities on its on one level or no
actual we're not there is
like that was like my messy and I will
say that the Catholics I mean there's a
close as I come to being Catholic is
thinking if you have small kids and your
spouse is not cheating on you or
addicted or abusive keep that marriage
together man I mean it's it is worth any
kind of sacrifice to keep that world
together for your kids doesn't it go to
that discussion you were having earlier
though about the you know the the
husband and the wife having to make the
major relationship themselves in order
to protect and provide a safe space for
the kids and it's like if the mother is
not remarrying because she's afraid of
what it would do for the child and it
makes her miserable is that really
helping the child sure I think I mean
they're okay it's a question you're
right and and and then to point it back
to the individual circumstance on on
some level and and and still preferring
creating those structures for the child
right your obligation in that
environment is to the child but it's
also you know drew you're talking about
sticking it out and part of what's hard
in that lesson especially because we get
such instant gratification now we're the
richest people who've ever existed we
have the most access to any pleasure any
superficial satisfaction that you could
ever actually use a VPN you know yeah
but it it people often frame their
divorces in these sort of along false
dichotomies like you just want me to be
unhappily married to this person to help
this kid and of course if the answer is
be unhappily married to protect the kid
the answer is yes but I just almost
always reject that those are your only
that's that's you can also salvage your
marriage you can build a better marriage
it goes back to that conversation from
very early on you're married to it
you're in an arranged marriage now
anyway the marriage that you have does
not have to be the marriage you have had
that's right that's right the the prices
I mean reaching this age you see some of
the friends you you grew up with and
grew old with the things they suffer
from worst are the little things they
didn't fix I mean it's it's not the it's
not the big mistakes we all make big
mistakes along the line but it's the
thing you do every single day and even
your friends say do you stop doing that
that's hurting you and you know it but
you don't do anything about it fix it
listen this is also why did I
think the only important decision you
make your entire life is who you marry I
really think it's the only important
decision because the kids that come
after that I mean half of all kids were
were conceived by accident we live in a
world where everybody is being planned
but the reality is that for virtually
all of human history half the time the
babies were premature so it really is
about that and this what my dad always
said when we were growing up which is
that there's really only one key
decision you're gonna make that you
cannot take back and that is the person
that you marry and if you do that right
the rest of your life is probably gonna
go find and if you do that wrong you are
going to eff up your life beyond all
recognition and I think that's essential
that means freak Alicia this is a
podcast so we could say it but I don't
think you would our final question for
not tonight comes from Brendan and it
goes back to a biblical question why
does the Bible choose to portray God as
a father when God is above and outside
the biological reality and limits of
male and female I think we have to let
Jeremy I'll a faster go floor and
they'll do the ribbiting versions I do I
do think this is part of what I was
speaking to a minute ago the question is
why why does the Bible represent God as
a father when God is obviously not
gendered in the way that you in the way
of the creation he's a middle-aged guy
with a mustache a big long white beard
and I think that the answer is because
of in God condescending as I said to to
us in a way that we can't comprehend God
and so part of the beauty of God is that
he makes himself if not comprehensible
at least encounter Irbil and part of how
he's done that is to take the traits
that a father the trait of husband to
call himself things like love to call
himself you know if you take like a
Galatians five it's in the sequel to if
you take the sort of fruits of the
spirit that means the the the virtues of
God right that the Spirit is God and
those are the fruits of God as patience
and kindness and long-suffering humility
that God God claims those as himself so
that we can begin to understand him and
then as we understand him and whatever
small way we're able we then begin to
understand those traits so it you know
that it flows both ways we we only can
understand God because he's given us
some context for understanding him and
in the context that he gives us he's
also expressed
saying something to us about our
experience of the world beyond him so
God isn't our father but a father is an
entry to understanding God and then God
is an entry to understanding what it is
to be a father and so why doesn't he use
you know as in some religions the
feminine you know Earth's mother the
idea because I think it's that God while
God does nurture us and give us life
which and even the Bible uses a few
feminine references to God and these
seven names without God but it primarily
uses masculine ones because unlike what
the pagans want us to think which is
that God is primarily about giving us
life and nurturing us God is actually
that's the beginning of what God did for
us what he goes on to do is shape us and
constrain us and then after constraining
us give us freedom and those are very
those are very paternal impulses you
know I often think of big government as
being the the perverse feminine values
that if the father gives you freedom the
father raises you to stand on your own
the father pushes you out of the nest
the father turns loose of you those are
those are our masculine impulses the the
perverse version of the feminine if the
good version of the feminine has give
life give nurturing the perverse version
is use the gift of nurturing to gain
power and control and so the you know
Reagan is the father figure of a
president because he says out of the
nest and on your own I'm gonna raise you
to be an adult and that I'm gonna trust
you I know you're gonna make mistakes
but I'm gonna trust you to make your own
way Obama is the mother of the country
who says no honey it's okay I'm gonna
take care of your rent and I'm gonna
take care of your healthcare but you
really shouldn't eat that that's so well
said that's CS lewis talks about that he
says you know and when he's explaining
christianity says Jesus is the only
begotten Son of God whatever that means
and he died for your sins
whatever that means I know I have a
finite intellect and I don't have the
divine logic of the universe
banging around in my head so I can't
explain what God the Father is right he
is that he is but I can know that God is
the father
gives me something it leads me there you
know that's our old friend uncle
Aristotle you know who's talked talked
about God is the prime mover the way he
moves is by drawing us to himself and
that's a very fatherly thing to do and
the Maimonides talks about the use of
homonyms in the bible and the use of the
idea that we're using constant human
descriptors for God in the way that
atheists read the Bible is they say well
that's because human beings are writing
the Bible so they're taking their own
vision of their father and then they are
taking it turning that into God is sort
of Freudian version right totem and
taboo that they're took your dad you
made him into God and that's why God is
the father and the way that that Jews
and Christians read this stuff is that
we can't describe God in any language
other than the language that we know and
so if God's trying to talk to us then
he's got to use language that we
understand was certain extent in Judaism
the there's the the basic kind of
division between male and female
typically on a spiritual level is the
division between justice and mercy so
mercy is considered a feminine quality
and justice is considered a masculine
quality which by the way is typically
how it works in the home I mean at least
that that is the way that it has worked
in my home just from natural just
naturally when it's time to bring the
hammer everyone calls dad right that's
just the way it goes like when it's time
for the hammer to come there's not a
teenage boy on planet earth who's afraid
of his mother not one right that's why
when the fathers aren't in the home the
boys are a disaster afraid of his mother
[Laughter]
one of the decisions that one of the
questions about God is his God primarily
a God of mercy or has God primarily a
God of justice and I'm not sure I'll be
interested to hear kind of the Christian
perspective on this but obviously the
Old Testament perspective is that God is
primarily a God of justice tempered by
Mercy that the the world is built along
certain laws and those laws operate in a
certain way and God can allow you to he
can be merciful toward you because if
you were not merciful toward you you
wouldn't exist right this is sort of the
story of Adam and Eve God says if you do
this your you will on that day you will
surely die but then he doesn't kill it a
long day right he doesn't he doesn't
kill that many if you basically he says
okay you're gonna die eventually which
is God saying okay if I were to just
punish sinners the way that sinners
deserve to be punished then everybody
would be gone now right but God says
okay well these rules still apply but I
will be merciful toward you and you
should be merciful to another because
I'm merciful towards you but in the end
God created a just system a system that
is that is built
on certain inevitable laws that if you
follow you will largely do better in
life and if you do not follow then there
will be certain things that happen you
as well
and so God is typically portrayed in the
masculine because if you are going to
say the primary quality of God the God
the primary quality of God is justice
which is interesting is when you go back
to Greek philosophy the main quality
inverter people are looking for
generally platonic virtue is justice
right so that it's interesting to see
how that sort of merges I would say the
Christian answer is yes that God is a
God of perfect justice and perfect mercy
and in that way God sort of you know
there's that old question can God make a
rock so big he can't carry it and the
answer is yes and then he made a
mechanism by which he could carry it so
God God has this duality that creates
this sort of unbridgeable tension of
being perfectly just and perfectly
merciful which doesn't matter if you're
only dealing with righteous beings you
can be perfectly merciful and perfectly
just and those are just abstracts when
he deals with us now there's a division
and so in the Christians since he then
created the mechanism to bridge those
two in in Christ in whom he is able to
pour out his justice as a mechanism of
pouring out his mercy pour out his
justice on Christ so the ticket part is
mercy on us Alicia thank you so much for
your I mean who needs a Wednesday night
Bible study when we have these Tuesday
night thank you so much for filled in
the questions for us tonight and thanks
to everybody who wrote in we love
hearing from our subscribers we joke a
lot about how we go g-guys for you know
all we give you is one lousy tumbler but
part of the reason that we do these
things that we do the conversation and
try to take questions and interact is
because we are so deeply appreciative
you guys make it possible for us at the
Daily wire to do what we do on an
ongoing basis and and and we're grateful
for it so thank you and we'll catch you
guys as far as questions go on the
conversation coming up with Ben and then
we're gonna do another one of these I
think around the fourth of July sometime
with a good special guest I'm probably
working them in the meantime before we
can adjourn for the night I think we've
got a few more minutes another segment
innocent I want to I want to turn to
Michael Michael was later Michael as
everyone knows who was invited nick was
recently married
in in New York two weeks ago and I am
certain that you can't have a
conversation about what it means to be a
husband without all the old hands and
the only life they have some wisdom to
impart that to the young buck so I would
caution you of course to take all of
this with a grain of salt
yeah but what let's go around and what
is the one piece of wisdom that you
would most you know don't go to bed
angry or I always say the key to
marriage is a two bathrooms in a
king-size bed what wisdom have you to
impart mr. Shapiro not to sweet little
ELISA Michael so you know some people
tell you to be yourself don't just don't
do it but in reality they I really think
that the key piece of advice is when
your spouse criticizes you listen
because your spouse is probably correct
and that's the hardest thing to do
because it for me it's very hard to do
because I mean look at me I'm
unbelievable but it is it is a difficult
thing to do because in the middle of you
know arguing or discussing or whatever
it is in the middle of the night when
you're deciding who has to get up and go
to kids you know it's it's very easy to
think okay well you know I did this last
night why is she why isn't she doing
this tonight and maybe it's because you
know she had a long day and maybe you're
being the one who's jerk I think that
just like if you wanna have a successful
life and this isn't record of you if you
don't have a drink because it's not
gonna happen for you but if you want in
the abstract if people want to have a
successful life they can't blame
everything that's happening around them
you have to you have to work on yourself
the same thing is true in marriage you
want to have a successful marriage you
can't change how your spouse reacts to
you you can't control your spouse's
feelings you're not responsible for your
spouse's happiness you're responsible
for being a better person and then
hopefully your spouse will be happier
because you're a better person but I
really don't think that you can you all
you can do is be a better person toward
toward your spouse and then beyond that
there it's it's just not in your control
I think you know it was fine I was
joking with with my group I guess
today's Tuesday so it was Monday I was
joking with him that all these all you
guys gave him such complicated advice
and my advice advice was don't sleep
with anybody else yeah
this is actually good advice but but you
know as someone I I have had and I've
written about this so it was not a
secret I've had this kind of
supernatural marriage of a genuine
romance that is going on now 40 years
and it's not it's a strange thing when
people ask me about it my first joke is
always you got to marry my wife but but
that but the key thing I always think is
like be nice you know be polite
I see people talk to their wives in ways
they would never talk to a waitress in
ways that we never talked to a stranger
named ways they never talked to somebody
at work and it just seems like that very
basic thing when you have something to
say say it politely you know I mean she
is still another human being she is
still a woman you know she still
deserves that kind of grace and
politeness and gentility that you bring
even you that got help and bring to
everybody around you you know you don't
push people aside in the street you
don't snap at people in restaurants you
don't do all those things and yet people
take that home and that's the first way
they react to an unwashed dish in the
sink or whatever it is and I just think
it's just that little stuck thing that
happens in it with every word you speak
you know that I think feeds into an
actual good marriage over something cuz
you see people do that all the time
they're mean to their family they're
means people organs to them and they're
nice to everybody I know and to me that
that is you getting it exactly wrong it
shouldn't be mean to anybody but if
you're gonna be mean to anybody
shouldn't be your spouse no should save
that for people on Twitter at this point
you're the reason I'm on Twitter I have
two pieces of advice my wife when we had
been married about 10 years we have
friends a couple that have been married
longer than us and she you know in a
moment of just despair goes what's the
secret how are you guys so happy and
Carl and Nancy our friends said lower
your expectations and things have been
better since then that's one thing and
and the other thing is there's another
slogan that I've had been hard for me to
learn but I think I've finally learned
it and my friend Russell Friedman who
ran the grief recovery and
that you used to tell me this ask
yourself do you want to be right or do
you want to be happy this is exactly
right exactly right yeah so you know
when you realize that you're fighting
over something just to be right then you
probably are giving up your happiness so
it's funny because you know all of us
all the time especially on Twitter but
you know in just political life it the
method of debate is always to smash the
other person right you got a like that's
the line right as so-and-so crushes
so-and-so and but when you're in a
marriage you don't want to crush them
you know because you have to sleep next
to them and wake up and have breakfast
together and so it's you know it's a
very different experience than the
professional life to your personal life
oh you I'll do two as well the first one
is you know there's there's the whole
Ephesians thing about husbands or the
head of the wife as Christ is the head
of the church and that's always very
offensive to women because they think
that men want what they want so women
don't like the idea that they have to
submit to their husbands because they
assume that their husband wants to rule
over them because they by and large want
to rule over their husband but in this
is actually the dual sacrifice there's
no such thing there's no such term in
our culture as the woman cave right
there's the man cave men don't want to
be in charge they don't want to be
responsible they're not as good at being
in charge they're not as good at being
responsible women are better at detail
they're better at multitasking they're
better at many of the things that a wife
has to trust her husband to be for her
and the husband can't stay in his
mancave and play video games which is
what he wants to do he has to leave
behind his childish ways of being
selfish and and an independent and now
come and make sacrifice on behalf of
someone else so so actually both parties
in the marriage are having to lay down
the thing that they want and step into a
role that's not natural for them in a
kind of optimistic faith in in the
institution of marriage and that's my
ultimate advice well I would add to that
that also remember that it says as
Christ loves the church which actually
means you know we often think of it in
terms of well I'm the husband I'm the
man I'm the leader but the analogy is
actually to teach you to be the bride of
God to be the one who is yeah who is the
other things which should give us some
also some sense of perspective on what's
being asked if the other person
but ultimately that's it is the
recognition that the other person isn't
you that they are fundamentally
different that you know you and your
wife will never actually agree on a
single thing and the the the way that
good marriages get you in trouble is
that because you don't have a lot of
conflict you think you agree and because
you have good conversation and say all
the same things you also think that you
agree and so you'll say like I love
popcorn and your wife will say I love
popcorn and you will think that what
that means is that your wife loves
popcorn but that is never what it seems
you are you are completely different
people you are completely differently
even the areas of your agreement are
actually unique and distinct and the
reason Nick's lower your expectations
advice is so great I think is because
it's it's actually just it's not lower
your expectations it's stop having these
expectations that you were never
promised that the other person will be
you they will see things the way that
you see things that they will want the
things that you want you have to
actually understand that they are other
and my last piece of what I think is
top-notch marriage advice is when when
worse comes to worse go to bed angry and
I mean this it's a little bit playful
but what I mean is sometimes you will
encounter a problem in your marriage
that one single night will not be able
to solve and the idea that never go to
bed angry is such as always struck me as
a superficial piece of advice like we're
gonna be able to work out the hardest
conflicts in life in a single moment but
sometimes all you can do is stop you go
to bed and going to bed is trusting the
institution of marriage it's it's
accepting that if I go to bed now I will
wake up tomorrow still married and that
the only way that your marriage
marriages don't end they are in bed and
the only way your marriage will be ended
is if you or your spouse in it and
sometimes there's just a there's a
surrender of faith of saying I am NOT
going to end this I don't know how to
fix it but the institution itself will
remain if I can just stop I have one
more I have one more so this is this is
one that I've used to marriage is a
great trick okay so
women do this thing okay and this thing
is that well at least my wife does this
and she knows that I'm going to talk
about this so she so what it is is that
women will ask you a question and and
they will talk to you about a situation
in their life and you will assume they
they want this situation solved do not
want the situation right they want the
situation listened to they want you to
listen okay men don't like this stuff
right men wait when you hear a problem
you want to fix it because you're a dude
but when your wife your wife just wants
the feeling of you having listened to
her so I have an actual rule in our
house which is that as soon as my wife
starts with this I will ask her is this
a solving conversation and it works
great it works great because my wife is
a good enough person and that she
understands that this will make our
relationship better if she actually
gives me an honest answer she'll say
okay I just want I just want you to hear
what I'm saying right now as opposed to
I want you to fix it because there's
nothing that pisses off a woman more
than her giving you a problem and you
trying to fix it when all she wants you
to do is listen to her problem this is
an amazing and that is so true I
remember the first time I encountered
this i sweet little ELISA had some
problem you know and explained it to me
and I said okay well you should do this
in this and then do this tomorrow and
then it'll be good you just want to fix
this what else am I supposed to this is
eternal advice yes forget everything
else don't sleep with will adjourn for
the evening on this the daily wire
backstage is sophomore effort yes I
think we gave it the old college all
right thank you guys for tuning in for
so very very long and we'll look forward
to seeing you again when we reconvene
here in a couple of weeks for episode
three
[Music]